Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt ausgabe zweiundzwanzig und das ist natürlich eine weitere ausgabe von corona weekly von mir tim und pavel.
Pavel pavel meier und ja jetzt ist mal wieder eine woche vergangen
die gelegenheit für uns all unsere weissagung unsere voraussagen zu überprüfen beziehungsweise die voraussagen von allen anderen und.
Vielleicht auch die aussagen von anderen zu diskutieren,
und es ist ja auch so einiges passiert sowohl im bereich des der zahlen werke als auch im bereich der diskussion um diese tracing apps und ich denke so wie wir es die letzten beiden sendungen schon gehalten haben machen wir es,
diesmal das heißt wir quatschen erstmal so ein bisschen über den ganzen zahlensalat der uns so entgegengehalten wird und was du vor allem noch so aus deinen eigenen nachbesprechungen herauslesen
konntest und danach werden wir nochmal auf diese frage von,
und was brauchen wir denn jetzt eigentlich und was hat sich denn da getan eingehen hat sich eine menge getan wenn er sicherlich schon alle mitbekommen haben,
diese ganze debatte die wir letzte woche nochmal nachvollzogen haben.
Rundum zentral dezentral das scheint jetzt erstmal so weit entschieden zu sein bundesregierung ist da umgeschwenkt und sitzt jetzt eben auch auf das dezentrale modell das ist etwas das kann man nur,
begrüßen und jetzt schauen wir dann im nachgang nochmal was sind das jetzt eigentlich bedeutet beziehungsweise welche anderen fragen
in diesem kontext aufkommen ich würde aber dann trotzdem erstmal mit etwas feedback anfangen ihr habt uns zu gehauen echt mit
kommentaren vielen dank dafür da war eine menge dabei fast jetzt mehr als man so prozessieren kann wir werden mal versuchen auf ein paar sachen einzugehen oder ein paar sachen zumindest hier kurz aufzugreifen
relativ viel,
wind gab es so um unsere debatte herum mit wirtin genug getan und was könnte denn mehr getan werden da waren dann einige leute die so ihre eindrücke aus der perspektive von gesundheitsämtern.
Situation
sie entweder genau begleiten oder wo sie vielleicht auch einen teil davon sind es nicht ganz klar da gab's dann aussagen mit bei uns in der region ist das so und so und läuft alles total super da stand jetzt leider nicht dabei und welche region es sich handelt weil ich vermute mal
dass eben die erfahrung auch jene nach region sehr unterschiedlich sein können.
Verschiedenste dinge auch auf anderen kanälen dann feedback für bekommen dass in vielen regionen wiederum die gesundheitsämtern in den letzten zehn zwanzig jahren.
Doch runtergefahren oder runter gespart worden sind und dann sind natürlich unterschiedliche regionen auch unterschiedlich stark betroffen oder in anspruch.
Waren also ich kann mir schon sehr gut vorstellen dass die regionale situation sehr unterschiedlich ist sowohl vom bundesland zu bundesland auch noch.
Und dann auch noch innerhalb der bundesländer insofern.
Ist es sicherlich teilweise besser aber was eben klar ist ist dass sozusagen die bundesweite vereinheitlichung des meldeweg.
Auch wenn es in einzelnen regionen besser geht wenn die hälfte oder ein drittel dann trotzdem nicht nachkommt relativ zeitnah dann ja hat man halt nur ein sehr unvollständigen.
Es gab auch so diverse hinweise dass es mit den test teilweise sehr schnell funktioniert sowohl bei hausärzten als auch bei kliniken die tests durchführen das tests wie wir das ja eigentlich angemahnt haben dann auch binden eines tages vorliegen
ja das kann alles sein das bis man natürlich im einzelnen so auch nicht wir berichten auch nicht aus der praxis,
das war auch sagen wir mal eher eine gesamtbetrachtung also uns ging's ja sozusagen darum dass eben ein system insgesamt geschaffen werden muss was
einerseits eben diese ganzen latenzen möglichst,
reduziert selbst wenn ein einzelner schritt mal schnell geht heißt es ja noch lange nicht dass der ganze turnaround dann auch schnell geht und ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau wie wir das positioniert haben aber da steht natürlich dann auch eben in dieser ganzen frage der,
apps.
Also man kann es auch ganz einfach sagen zehn komma fünf tage sagt es vergehen zwischen infektionen und
meldung also bis jemand im schnitt auftaucht einige kürzer aber ganz ganz viele halt erst später und wenn man jetzt sagt dass auch nach fünf komma fünf tagen im schnitt,
beginnen heißt dass das zwischen symptom beginn und bis jemand in der statistik auftaucht halt immer noch,
fünf tage vergehen.
Da aber halt glaube ich einfach nur ein beispiel auch gebracht dass man wahrscheinlich vier von den fünf tagen einsparen könnte wenn man das richtig organisiert.
Hinweis gab es auch zu den von dir geforderten corona taxis die gibt es nämlich in hamburg aber es wurde auch gleich dazu gesagt dass es eben auch nicht besonders gut skaliert das ist natürlich ein,
problem letztlich sind all diese maßnahmen einzelmaßnahmen und es kommt natürlich auf das ganze paket an
all diese ganzen maßnahmen müssen kombiniert werden um eben diese beschleunigung im melde wesen zu erreichen.
Bezüglich der lockerung maßnahmen,
hatten wir uns ja auch gefragt warum denn diese achthundert quadratmeter regel denn eingeführt wurde wo denn diese zahl herkommt sieht so aus als ob das eine entleerung aus dem baurecht ist also bestimmte
geschäfte mit einer fläche von mehr als achthundert quadratmeter gelten dann als sonderbar guten
da gilt dann auch ein anderer brandschutz und überhaupt generell andere regeln und gewisser hinsicht war das wohl die naheliegende schwellenwert grenze in dem moment um dann unterschied zu machen und die motivation dahinter schien schlicht zu sein und das kann ich
gerade für berlin sehr gut nachvollziehen dass man eben bei der eröffnung.
Nicht unbedingt sofort das ganze signal an die umstände größerer städte von den oberzentren gibt so ja shop
hat wieder auf ihr könnt euch jetzt alle wieder in die regionalzügen setzen und ordentlich einkaufen
ob das so gut funktioniert hat weiß ich nicht es gab ja dann auch gleich hier auch in berlin diese diskussion ich glaube das hatten wir auch kurz erwähnt so was ist denn jetzt mit einer shopping maul wo ganz viele läden unter achthundert quadratmeter sind aber die shopping mall an sich ist eben größer
lief darauf hinaus dass dann diese läden eben auch alle aufmachen durften und ich glaube teilweise ist es jetzt auch schon so dass kaufhäuser dann entweder achthundert quadratmeter bereiche.
Abgesperrt haben et cetera ich denke mal dass das sind halt solche prozesse.
Man muss auch glaube ich ein bisschen mitleid haben oder zumindest nachvollziehen.
Dass die politik die jetzt hier entscheiden muss also vor allem eben die lokale politik die ja dann auch gezwungen ist diese ganzen maßnahmen umzusetzen und auf ihre lokalen gegebenheiten anzupassen.
Ja einfach auch in so einer situation ist es das haben die halt so in der form auch noch nicht gehabt die sind oder im extremen druck die sind auch unter einer extremen beobachtung und fehler passieren und letzten endes,
lohnt es meist gar nicht sich da groß aufzuregen ich denke hier nur an das beispiel in berlin mit der parkbank dass dann irgendwie leute von der parkbank verscheucht wurden klar das war dann irgendwie auch blöd und das wurde dann auch schnell geändert und das ist halt jetzt auch alles gar kein thema mehr.
Ja die debatte sagen jetzt lokal und global beziehungsweise föderale
die geht jetzt gerade los wie weit man war ja eh schon so dass ganz viele sachen jeweils ins benehmen der bundesländer gestellt wurden man will aber jetzt natürlich auch nicht in jedem bundesland,
völlig andere regeln haben so das ist das problem auf der anderen seite sind,
die verhältnisse aber regional unterschiedlich so und das heißt man ist jetzt in dieser ganzen verordnung geschichte so ein bisschen zwischen ja wir
müssen es eigentlich anpassen auf die lokalen gegebenheiten weil es gibt.
Gegnern und städte da ist wahrscheinlich gar kein infiziertes so aber gut man weiß es halt nicht und andere da ist es halt begegnen da laufen halt schon noch.
Nennenswert viele leute rum die sich jeden tag anstecken und die krankheit weitertragen und,
willst du natürlich nicht alle über einen kamm scheren aber dann sind wir schon irgendwie ein land auch mit wirtschaftsverbände und
pendler strömen und einkäufer strömen und so weiter und ja
und die will man natürlich zu einem gewissen grad zulassen beziehungsweise bringt nicht wenn wenn das eine land zwei leuten erlaubt auszureisen aber niemand sie einreisen lässt so oder umgekehrt
egal aber das ist jedenfalls jetzt auch der konflikt und da können wir vielleicht später auch noch zu war halt auch thema heute auf der,
pressekonferenz vom robert-koch-institut.
Kurz noch feedback dann hatten wir das diesjährige liste erwähnt und auch gelobt als beispiel für
guck mal wie schnell das gehen kann wenn sich hier eine organisation anstrengend da mal schnell digital was auf die kante zu kriegen und
gab es einen kommentar dass da die rettungsleitstellen nicht ganz so begeistert waren von diesem buch da gibt's nämlich in der tat schon ein digitales system was,
jetzt so ein bisschen das problem hat das quasi zwei systeme gewesen während also dieses dirigismus jetzt,
gewisser hinsicht für die politik und die öffentlichkeit so eine übersicht schafft sahen sich dann.
Die leitstellen in der situation dass krankenhäuser doppelt eintragen müssen weil das macht man sich ja dann glaube ich auch nicht so richtig klar natürlich gibt es schon solche.
Belegungszahl datenbanken die vor allem eben rettungsstellen brauchen da ruft einer an sagt hier vorfall,
tralala da müssen die halt auch entscheiden wo geht's hin also wo welches krankenhaus hat jetzt platz für diesen fall.
Problem ist.
Alle nutzen diese systeme so ist es es gibt halt nicht irgendwie das bundeseinheitliche system und das haben sie halt mit dem dezentral register zumindest geschaffen
so und das war tatsächlich auch wichtig trotz all dem perso und
rollout eines bundeseinheitliche systems auf basis dessen was da teilweise in unterschiedlichen rettungs-
leitstellen läuft das ist wahrscheinlich einen,
it-unternehmen ins,
sozusagen man kann das eine vielleicht auch nicht mit dem anderen so hundertprozentig vergleichen aber
fakt ist dass es die die zentralregister sagen relativ zeitnahe bundesweite gesamtübersicht geliefert hat.
Sag mal einen großteil siebzig achtzig neunzig prozent.
Dann der relevanten betten dann auch gemeldet worden und es war auch wichtig weil das halt geschehen halt so dynamisch war so insofern sie sagen trotz aller mängel und kritik so an dem ding
so ja die existierenden systeme waren,
einfach nicht gewachsen oder geeignet bundesweit das zu tun.
Dann.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf diese auf diese artikel noch eingehen wollte ich noch an einen anderen kommentar vor voranstellen ich würde darauf hingewiesen ich würde ja immer der virus sagen und du wahrscheinlich auch oder.
Nee nee.
Du bist bis fraktion das virus.
Ach so nein ich dachte meins ich wurde darauf angesprochen nein.
Du wolltest ja wir wurden drauf angesprochen was würdest du denn jetzt mal so intuitiv sagen.
Ah ich glaube ich würde üblicherweise irgendwie das virus verwenden ja.
Eher das virus aber ich würde jetzt auch sagen in bestimmten situationen wo ich das gefühl hab sprachlich passt das besser würde ich auch der virus sagen
der virus ein bisschen umgangssprachliche aber keine ahnung was hast du was.
Geht's mir nämlich auch und ich habe mich so ein bisschen schlau gemacht wird jetzt hier keinen großen vortrag darüber halten aber tatsächlich ist es so also das wort kommt aus dem lateinischen,
und die argumentation dass man.
Doch das virus sagen sollte ja einerseits weil der herr trosten das immer sagt ist weil das ja im lateinischen auch ein neu drum ist.
Das ist auch richtig und es ist halt so in der wissenschaft ist wird es generell so gehalten dass wenn man ein wort aus dem lateinischen als fachbegriff verwendet dass man dann auch.
Den genus aus dem lateinischen wie er dort war nimmt.
Und deswegen sagen alle wissenschaftler das virus und deswegen hören wir das jetzt überall und frau merkel sagt auch dass virus aber das ist ja auch wissenschaftlerin.
Ich weiß worauf das hinausläuft falls du es noch nicht gemerkt hast aber ja nein.
Was.
Und zwar je nachdem ob du.
Virus des eingedeutschte also ob du den das deutsche wort virus nimmst oder das lateinische wort virus.
Genau das ist aber die die die die kurzfassung.
Und ohne jetzt soweit rausgreifen zu wollen aber es ist halt grundsätzlich so dass das ingo germanische ja,
aus dem ja auch unsere sprache abstammt so kennt halt noch und ist ja auch sagen wir mal inhalt auch
permanenter gesellschaftlicher auseinandersetzung ja dass dass wir immer so zum zum zum maskulinum neigen und all alle generalisieren den begriffe zumindest in den letzten jahrzehnten halt immer so bei dir man sagt halt ne.
Der hörer und so weiter also auch was sozusagen die die mengen bildung betrifft und so weiter auf jeden fall.
Ist es einfach in im germanischen schon so gewesen dass quasi sprachlich.
Neutrale und das feminine sind sozusagen die ausnahmen und es maskuline ist der dvd ich sage nicht dass das soll so sein ich sage nur,
ich habe das jetzt so erfahren dass das aus dem menschen so übernommen wird und damit eben unsere sprache auch prägt und das,
generell halt das maskuline verwendet wird für alles was im im satz sozusagen als als subjekt steht im malischen.
Und insbesondere und es kommt noch so ein bisschen dazu
der wir auch dazu dass alles was irgendwie so ein so ein so ein so ein akteur ist ja in diese rolle kommt also alles was irgendwie insbesondere was du so ein bisschen so so gemein ist und so ein feind ist und einem irgendwie was weg.
Oder eine bedrohung so so so ein täter ist.
Der der virus ist es böse dass virus ist so ja.
Genau ne also das rein vom vom wortstamm ist es ja so virus heißt halt eigentlich das was fließt ja
weil man eben früher gar nicht wusste was der verursacher dieser krankheiten ist und deswegen bezeichnet es eben so schleim ausfluss und so weiter also das im wesentlichen worin,
man hat eigentlich erst später durch filterung und so weiter festgestellt dass er halt noch irgendwas kleines drin ist was sozusagen das eigentlich übernimmt und damit es virus eigentlich von seiner.
Bedeutung auch schon entkoppelt weil es ist nicht mehr das was fließt das ist halt dieser,
der bösewicht der uns irgendwie ans fell will naja auf jeden fall ich habe bei mir festgestellt ich habe schon irgendwie immer der virus gesagt und ich.
Bedenkt rechner auch damit das auch herr trosten da ist gehabe nicht.
Beeinflussen kann ist auch egal also egal ob ihr nun das oder der virus sagen es war dasselbe virus gemeint.
Dann gab es noch ein hinweis auf einen artikel den wir glaube ich nochmal genauer angeschaut hast bei telepolis.
Genau vielleicht nur ganz kurz es ist auf jeden fall eine interessanter artikel viele mit vielen auch guten gedanken und.
Richtigen berechnungen allerdings kommt er dann am ende zu dem schluss es hätte gar keine so rasante exponentielle ausbreitung gegeben.
Das.
Also der artikel heißt von der fehlenden wissenschaftlichen begründung der corona maßnahmen von christoph kubaner der bei telepolis erschienen.
Und.
Es geht auch im wesentlichen darum wie probleme behaftet die zahlen sind durch welche effekte,
die auswertung der zahlen so alles erschwert wird und was alles die zahlen so verzerrt und da hat er sich wirklich.
Gute gedanken gemacht und ganz gut auch rausgearbeitet noch ganz viele andere.
Verzerrung faktoren die eine die eine rolle spielen also lohnt sich schon anzuschauen aber leider am ende so von wirklich eigentlich vielen interessanten seiten zieht er dann daraus den,
ich meine auch nicht zulässigen schluss es hätte,
gar keinen exponentiellen anstieg gegeben das einzige was ich aber sagen würde ist so erstens okay.
Es hat definitiv diesen anstieg gegeben von einigen vielleicht dutzend eingeschleppt infektionen hin zu.
Jetzt mittlerweile hunderttausenden so das heißt der ist da und er ist nur nicht.
Den zahlen so einfach zu entnehmen wann er denn wie eigentlich stattgefunden hat und da habe ich halt auch nachher noch ein paar.
Dinge zu herausgefunden den ich auch noch erzählen möchte aber wie sagt der artikel grundsätzlich empfehlenswert ihn zu lesen allerdings so die schlüsse die daraus gezogen werden teile ich nicht.
Dann schauen wir doch mal was die aktuellen zahlen so sagen was hast du denn diese woche angeschaut und was haben die nach berechnungen die du angestellt hast dir denn so alles neues erzählt.
Gehen wir gleich in die zahlen wenn ich dachte machen vielleicht die pressekonferenz noch vorher aber.
Ach so wenn du das erwähnen möchtest zuerst gerne.
Ja das ist vielleicht die auch die unterhaltsamere unterhaltsamere teil von den von den zahlen.
Wie du möchtest ich kann das nicht einschätzen.
Ja ja gut also
mein heute vormittag am achtundzwanzigsten vierten hat halt wieder eine ich glaube wahrscheinlich stattfindende pressekonferenz
des robert-koch-instituts stattgefunden und da hat der leiter professor doktor lothar vila.
Hat dort etwa rund eine stunde so erzählt was es neues gibt am robert-koch-institut und mit corona.
Journalisten geantwortet die alle remote zugeschaltet weil er nicht alle aber fast alle und ansonsten würde es über periscope,
übertragen interessantes setting das ganze so und ja war halt auch mal so ein interessanter blick so in die in die klassische medienwelt.
Es wurde dann auch sehr viel zu kritisch nachgefragt.
Aber bemerkenswerter fand ich die debatte zum thema ob die kirchen denn jetzt auch demnächst wieder aufmachen können.
Da habe ich mir war mir gar nicht klar welche tiefe debatte da gerade im im im im gange ist weil
natürlich ja das das bedürfnis auch der menschen sich religiös zu sammeln es verfassungsmäßig geschützt und da kann man halt stehen zu wie man will aber,
ein problem natürlich ist das herausgefunden hat es gerade so singen und laut sprechen,
in geschlossenen räumen mit einer größeren zahl von leuten so situationen sind wo es gut und gerne mal zum super spreding
so wie der chor wo sich nach einer stunde singen ich glaube fünfundvierzig von sechzig leuten angesteckt haben.
Berichtete.
Und jetzt machen die kirchen aber nun konzepte für sichere gottesdienste so,
wurde berichtet dass sie halt auch irgendwie social distanz und so werden kann man heute in der
pressekonferenz sind auch die berechtigte frage ob's denn jetzt dein gottesdienste ohne singen und beten denn geben wird und ob man das der wirklich braucht
vor allem wo da doch auch so viele alte leute hinkommen die doch zu risikogruppe gehören und im korea des super hat ja auch
im rahmen religiöser zeremonien stattgefunden also.
Muss sich wirklich die frage stellen wie wichtig ist es oder wie gefährlich ist das gerade
ja gut
ich bin gespannt die kirchen ich meine das sind auch nicht nur idioten so die werden sich da sicherlich auch schon gedanken zu machen und die richtigen,
ziehen und das ist schon irgendwie hinkriegen und die leute werden sicherlich auch.
Denke ich genau darüber nachdenken wie wichtig ihnen das jetzt ist beistand zu suchen in der kirche oder nicht also.
Ja
die erde butte war etwas kurios also ein journalist hat dort auch dann die ärzte zahlen angezweifelt vom hat gesagt er kann das überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen wie sie irgendwie jetzt
auf die zahl von eins kommen so alle rechnungen
die würden auf null komma acht oder unter null komma neun hinweisen ist auch die zahlen die ich kriege im übrigen und dann war erstmal die antwort naja.
Also die eins sei gerundet sie hätten ja irgendwie null komma neun sechs wären's ja in wirklichkeit gewesen aber sie hätten das halt dann,
eins aufgerundet so das war dann der erste hinweis und deswegen hätte er ja auch nicht ganz unrecht somit seinen unter null komma neun so das fand ich jetzt schon mal,
ein bisschen unpräzise zumal eins und null komma neun macht halt schon doch einen erheblichen unterschied so
und ich hatte jetzt nicht das gefühl
dass die stärken von herrn vila jetzt unbedingt im bereich der mathematik liegen so er mag ein guter biologe oder
direktor sein und sicherlich auch kennt sicherlich auch die grundzüge aber
das war jetzt nicht so also das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht so in erster linie sein thema glaube ich die berechnung und verwies dann halt immer auf das international
anerkannte cast verfahren ist allerdings auch so eine so eine,
berliner ding meines wissens also ich hab's anders wo nicht gesehen oder gefunden also es ist auf jeden fall in berlin erfunden muss ja deswegen nicht schlecht sein aber es ist jetzt.
Ist jetzt auch eher so ein bisschen was aus was haus hat halt so ein bisschen den geruch von was hauseigenen muss deswegen nicht nicht schlecht sein aber ist jetzt auch nicht so der internationale standard,
auch das problem steht auch in irgendeinem der papiere die er wahrscheinlich auch nicht gelesen hat die das ärger iso rausgibt so die boulette das halt,
man bei der erbe rechnung wenn man jetzt internationale vergleichbarkeit haben will man wohl eher einen anderes verfahren anwenden müsste weil er aus anderen ländern gar nicht die daten vorliegen die man braucht um halt,
so eine zu machen und dieses now cast läuft im wesentlichen dorf hinaus dass man aus den früheren.
Gehenden fällen versucht auszurechnen wie viele jetzt verspätet noch eingehen.
Also es ist quasi auch so eine art vorhersage verfahren was so ein bisschen weiter vorne an der pipeline ansetzt aber dieses weiter vorne an der pipeline ansetzen.
Gibt's halt nicht überall und.
Andere problematik haben wir vielleicht auch mit diesem mit diesem ist.
Das hat dort immer noch wöchentliche schwankungen drin in seinen ärger graf wobei sie im moment keine veröffentlichen so also keine aktuellen halt alle etwas noch noch älter und.
Bisher konnte immer noch niemand auskunft geben ich bin ja der meinung mittlerweile also es ist fast alles,
eine melde geschichte und nicht wirklich das infektionsgefahr gehen das spielt vielleicht auch eine rolle aber es ist.
Ganz ganz großen allergrößten teil halt die melde.
Verzögerung durchs wochenende die halt da so eine unruhe oder generell verarbeitungsverzeichnis die da so eine unruhe im wochen,
rythmus raus bringt und was mich halt einfach nur stört ist dass das teilweise von der zunahme redet in bestimmten zeitpunkten wo ich ganz klar sagen kann das ist eine,
definitiv eine woche eine woche schwankung so und,
das stärkt halt jetzt mein mein vertrauen nicht unbedingt auch wenn man jetzt nicht so weit auseinander liegt und wie sie jetzt auf die null komma neun sechs kommen ja.
Also ich weiß zwar wie sie's wie sie es theoretisch also wie die berechnungen aussehen aber wir werden sehen so.
Deren vorhersage gut funktioniert.
Hatte ich auf jeden fall nicht so umgehauen die pressekonferenz.
Hört mich nicht so umgehauen ich meine waren waren ich jetzt alles mist waren überwiegend auch.
Sicherlich gute und richtige hinweise und so aber gerade an den stellen wo ich mir ein bisschen mehr aufklärung erhofft hätte nämlich wie gesagt bei den.
Wöchentlichen schwankungen dass sich da mal jemand einfach zu äußert.
Aber es hat jetzt auch keine keine explizit gefragt in diese richtung.
Nein.
Also es wurde da zwar irgendwie wurde zwar angesprochen dass es halt wöchentliche schwankungen gibt aber nicht eben sollten ja für die erbe rechnung keine rolle spielen
und bei der erbe rechnung problem aber da kommen wir kommen wir dann.
Nämlich auch gleich schon zu den aktuellen zahlen aber vielleicht noch doch noch aus der pressekonferenz so das thema mit den test kapazitäten.
Da
Ist es so dass die aktuell bei weitem nicht ausgeschöpft sind es gibt jetzt auch meldungen wir haben hätten eine test kapazität so von acht neunhunderttausend tests die woche und durchgeführt werden so drei vierhunderttausend.
Ungefähr das heißt man könnte da mehr als doppelt so viele tests durchführen und.
Baden-württemberg hat ja jetzt auch eben eingeführt dass jetzt zumindest jetzt in krankenhäusern und in altenheimen des personal auch,
getestet werden soll ohne dass die symptome haben müssen sondern die halt einfach mit zu screen und ja.
Eine empfehlung ist das aber nicht beziehungsweise eigentlich nur so eine halbe könnte man denken so.
Was hier alten heime zu testen.
Ja ja genau also er standpunkt ist halt stand heute morgen pressekonferenz.
Ja es soll nicht jeder getestet werden sondern es soll eigentlich nach wie vor nur verdachtsunabhängig getestet werden was auch immer das,
heißt dann aber man sollte doch lieber früher.
Zu viel als später und zu wenig testen das ist sozusagen jetzt die empfehlung so also irgendwo zwischen doch eigentlich nicht alle nicht jeder der will,
also das sagt ja auch nicht jeder der will sollen test kriegen wo ich mich dann auch frage wo ist denn jetzt der unterschied zwischen,
jeder der will wahrscheinlich wäre das nicht aus laut aussprechen sondern immer noch den ärzten die möglichkeit geben irgendwelche hypochonder die sich jeden tag testen lassen wollen zu sagen jetzt ist aber schluss du hast jetzt schon drei tests diese woche,
das reicht jetzt aber.
Punkt ist das halt so ein bisschen der vorwurf auch anders er kam rangetragen wurde ja warum testen wir nicht mehr.
Er hat gesagt wir sind nicht schuld oder villa sagt es wir wir sind ja nur indirekt involviert in das testen ich meine was für ein haufen bullshit.
Das gibt vor sagen die regeln wer getestet wird und nicht und steuert damit natürlich ganz direkt
die test kapazitäten ausgeschöpft sind oder nicht wahrscheinlich hat nur keiner so richtig draufgeguckt und man wollte jetzt auch nicht so den großen produzieren oder so aber.
Ja ich fürchte man hat ein bisschen viel gespart und ausgerechnet die schwaben haben jetzt angefangen zu sagen nee das ist uns jetzt aber ein bisschen zu schwäbisch was ihr hier mit den tests macht.
Ja gut ich meine muss so ein test kostet natürlich auch geld so ich glaube irgendwas in der größenordnung von so fünfundachtzig euro oder so wenn das letzte was ich gehört habe.
Das sind alles kosten die auch von irgendjemand getragen werden müssen das sagt nicht dass das ist jetzt der wichtigste teil davon sondern das auf jeden fall teil,
der gesamtrechnung andererseits ist es auch ganz sinnvoll noch kapazitäten frei zu haben und es wird ja auch sehr viel
getestet so im allgemeinen screening also der droste wird ja auch nicht müde zu sagen seinen podcast das a deutschland halt schon immer sehr viel überdurchschnittlich viel getestet hat und vor allem das fand ich auch in der heutigen ausgabe nochmal ganz interessant dass du nochmal darauf hingewiesen hat
der ausbruch in deutschland ist ja nicht.
Dadurch festgestellt worden dass leute symptome hatten sondern man hat das quasi schon vorher bei dem mittesten von grippe fällen also so einen regelmäßigen getestet was ohnehin immer gemacht wird.
Wobei das echt glück war es war auch glückssache so das war jetzt nicht so ich glaube das war nur ein oder zwei patienten.
Ja gut aber dafür macht man das ja sozusagen also es wird einfach pauschal getestet und dann war der saß zwei test halt verfügbar man gesagt ok mach mal den mal mit und dann ist es halt ins netz gegangen aber genau dafür sind ja diese.
Diese standards trainings dann auch da und es hat ja an der stelle dann eben auch funktioniert da kann man jetzt nicht sagen das war glück also es.
Das war doch das war insofern war das war das halt glück des relativ früh ins netz gegangen ist
obwohl er also man hätte auch noch mehr glück haben können und.
Früher noch früher das finden können aber weil die die die zahlen also es gab halt einfach nicht so viele infizierte und wenn wir halt jetzt tausend leute testest in diesem screening aber nur jeder hunderttausendste ist krank dann musst du halt echt
so einen dabei hast das meine ich mit glück.
Ja klar aber ich wollte ja nur darauf hinaus es wurde ja eine vorleistung erbracht bevor.
War glück und verstand.
Ja genau bevor irgendeiner schon hier in der virus panik war war das system schon dabei,
test entwickeln test an die labore geben also über das heißt ja auch technik prozeduren chemikalien etcetera ich weiß nicht was da alles im einzelnen zugehört aber ist ja nicht so dass du irgendwo sehen den saß kopf zwei schalter umlegst und dann wird halt dann darauf getestet sondern das muss
getan werden und systematisch in den prozess mit integriert werden.
Und da muss man sagen da macht es auch eine super arbeit muss man sagen ich meine.
Es war der test von rosten der der erste war der bei der weltgesundheitsorganisation verfügbar war zum runterladen sage ich mal.
Mit den entsprechenden sequenzen die man bräuchte und samples und was sie da nicht,
alles bereit gestellt hatten also sie waren tatsächlich die ersten die auch einen test dafür hatten.
Was bemerkenswert ist und ja.
Da kann man zurecht auch ein bisschen stolz drauf drauf sein sodass auch was richtig gemacht worden.
Also nur weil sie nicht weil sie nicht so richtig gut ausrechnen könnte ich schätze heißt das nicht dass sie irgendwie in allen bereichen irgendwie nicht exzellente arbeit.
Machen so und vielleicht noch eine letzter punkt noch aus der aus der.
Pressekonferenz kann sich jeder gerne vielleicht selber mal reinhören ich meine ist jetzt nicht das spannendste ereignis gewesen aber
es gab noch die aussage dass wir tausend fälle pro tag angeblich tracken könnten also tausend neue erkrankungen das heißt,
im prinzip.
Wäre das sozusagen ist das jetzt so ein bisschen die grenze von neu erkrankungen die er damit faktisch gesetzt hat über die wir unter die wir fallen müssten damit wir,
in ein anderes wieder ins tracking regime übergehen können aber er hat natürlich auch betont der villa
dass das natürlich regional sehr sehr unterschiedlich sein kann und dass die tausend fälle halt wiederum im bundesdurchschnitt ist das heißt wenn es zu einem ausbruch in irgendeiner gegend kommt einem besonders heftigen dann kann das trotzdem bedeuten dass
dort nicht komplett getrackt werden kann aber dafür gibt es jetzt auch irgendwelche tracking scout teams oder so habe ich jetzt gehört gelesen die dann losgeschickt werden sollen die dann auch schnell dann.
An den ort eines ausbruchs eilen und dort die mannschaft verstärken,
da passieren halt auch dinge so dass es falls ja der der offizielle stand.
Aber sehr interessante zahl die können wir uns gleich mal merken wenn wir jetzt zur zahlen auswertung kommen als weiteres ziel damit nicht immer nur über ärger gesprochen wird.
Ok ja.
Kommen wir nochmal zur zahlen situation.
Ja aktuellen zahlen habe ich heute tatsächlich nur für deutschland mitgebracht weil ich einige dinge etwas näher auf die spur gegangen bin unter anderem den mysterium nochmal aber.
Erstmal.
Sieht es jetzt so aus dass die wir so auf hundertachtzig bis hundertneunzigtausend infizierte in der spitze also bis zum eventuellen plateau.
Hinauslaufen so in einigen wochen.
Plateau im sinne von wenn die neue infektionen runtergehen.
Wenn wir tatsächlich die,
neuinfektionen oder komplett erstmal das wachstum eingedämmt kriegen also es ist wohl auch eine leichte saisonalität zu erwarten.
Kann man nicht genau sagen die uns ein bisschen auch noch entgegenkommt deswegen ja die sache mit dass es im herbst wieder wieder ausbricht weil man schon damit rechnet.
Einfach so oder so wahrscheinlich erst mal runtergehen wird dass man es jetzt erstmal runterdrücken wird und.
In der geschwindigkeit wie es jetzt runtergedrückt wird laufen wir auf hundertachtzig hundertneunzigtausend infizierte raus es geht.
Aber nicht mehr schneller runter so sondern tendenziell eher langsamer.
Als es eigentlich sein könnte oder als es in anderen ländern der fall ist aber nichts dran nicht dramatisch.
Und in den bildern mache ich halt immer so platz wo ich halt immer so gucke wie verändern sich eigentlich die kurven.
Im laufe der zeit und wenn man da hab ich dann halt mal die letzten zwanzig tage übereinander gelegt und da zeigt es halt.
Sich das in die kurven.
Bei den infizierten zahlen weiter nach oben hin auswandern und aber die die schätzung jetzt mit hundertachtzig bis hundertneunzigtausend plateau berücksichtigt das ganze schon.
So das mit dem auswandern ist halt deswegen interessant weil man das bei der zahl der toten noch nicht sehen kann die ist jetzt seit
neun tagen entwickelt sich da die kurve völlig stabil die täglichen werte treffen da fast
fast präzise ein so mit zehn zwanzig prozent plus minus höchstens also wir.
Liegen ziemlich genau auf der kurve was so die wöchentlichen schwankungen betrifft die doch erheblich sind.
Aber ja die werte schwanken halt wie erwartet ziemlich genau auf der kurve mit.
Wie von dir erwartet oder wie vom.
Ja ne wie von mir erwartet so dass er macht jetzt keine vorhersagen von melde zahlen beziehungsweise.
Nicht so im wochenrückblick nicht so in der genauigkeit mich verträglich.
Also die morgendliche zahl im übrigen müsste also morgen und übermorgen müsste es nochmal wieder bei den gemeldeten toten zahlen etwas nach oben gehen bevor es dann.
Wahrscheinlich in drei tagen wieder beginnt zu singen.
Also morgen ich glaube ich habe schon wieder vergessen das datum zu sagen zum beginn dieser sendung also wir nehmen heute auf am achtundzwanzigsten april zwanzig so sendung wird mit glück am neunundzwanzigsten veröffentlicht sein also am
mittwoch und worauf du dich jetzt beziehst ich sehe die grafiken auch so ein bisschen schwierig jetzt in so einem podcast über solche grafiken zu reden.
Aber prinzip gibt's ja zwei methoden wie man hier diesen ganzen geschehen,
aussagen abbringen kann das eine ist halt man schaut sich an die zahl der neu infizierten und macht daraus eine schlussfolgerung dass es auch das was man zuerst bist und das ist halt auch immer wieder diese offene fragestellung,
ok kriegen wir überhaupt alle getestet und dunkelziffer und all diese ganzen sachen und etwas verlässlicher wenn auch nicht ganz ohne fragezeichen ist natürlich die zahl der gemeldeten toten die lassen sich so ohne weiteres erstmal nicht weg,
bleibt natürlich dann immer noch diese debatte sind ja auch alle mitgezählt worden die
daran oder mit dem virus verstorben sind oder entgehen uns hier welche wenn ihr irgendwelche nicht mitgezählt das kann man jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres beantworten was da jetzt konkret mit zählt wurde oder nicht trotz alledem.
Während wenn man die neu infizierten sich anschaut,
hat sich so in den letzten tagen da eine entwicklung gezeigt dass das was du aus den zahlen hast herauslesen können für die nächste zeit.
Ein bisschen die zahl ein bisschen höher liegen als erwartet während wenn man sich jetzt die todesrisiko anschaut das alles im rahmen der voraussagen ist so.
Jetzt das was du gesagt hast.
Letztlich betreibt das natürlich wird das alles getrieben durch durch den berühmten durch die berühmte reproduktion zahlen die effektivere produktionszeit die sich halt verändert.
Ich beziehe halt gleichförmige veränderungen der reproduktion schon ein aber also wenn's jetzt statt im durchschnitt immer wärmer zu werden das würden meine rechnungen.
Mit berücksichtigen aber wenn jetzt ein plötzlicher kälteeinbruch kommt oder und das ganze
wie gesagt hohe saisonalität hat oder wenn irgendwelche maßnahmen gelockert oder verschärft werden
das sind natürlich dinge die keines der modelle wirklich vorhersehen kann kann die natürlich dann wiederum abschätzen weil man weiß dass sie passieren weil es ja dann erst später kommt.
Aber das interessante eben an dem vergleich der dieser beiden kurven wie du schon gesagt hast die.
Gemessenen oder der ddr,
diagnostizierten neuinfektionen und die der diagnostizierten verstorbenen haben andere dunkelziffern sind unterschiedlich verlässlich und sind aber zeitlich natürlich auch verschoben.
Weil wir ja in eineinhalb von zehneinhalb tagen im durchschnitt zwischen infektion und auftauchen in der statistik vergehen.
Es ist halt eher so dass zwischen erkrankung und versterben
gibt es unterschiedliche zahlen zwischen zwanzig und dreißig tage dauert das im im durchschnitt hängt von verschiedenen faktoren ab so,
und dann kommt natürlich da auch noch eine meldet verzögerung bei den verstorbenen die aber wieder auch eine andere meldet verzögerung ist als bei den tests bei den erkrankten weil die ja in der regel feuer schon getestet worden.
Sind wenn sie als corona opfer gelten die meisten jedenfalls davon weil man erst auch in letzter zeit zu übergegangen ist überhaupt auch tote zu diagnostizieren wobei das mit.
Meiner meinung nach immer noch die absolute ausnahme situation ist außer wenn es irgendwie.
Umstände vielleicht im altersheim oder so umstände vielleicht für eine epidemie sprechen dann kann ich mir das vorstellen dass auch aber so im normalfall glaube ich immer noch nicht und,
jedenfalls kann man natürlich jetzt dann diese kurven so versuchen.
Nebeneinander zu legen und zu betrachten und ach ja für für die erbe rechnung vielleicht auch noch warum das halt immer.
So ein bisschen schwierig ist auch mit diesem mit diesem cast ich war gesagt die die zahlen laufen zehneinhalb tage hinterher.
Die erbe rechnung selbst aber nimmt ja die letzten acht tage die ersten vier gegen die nächsten vier was halt heißt.
Das sind weitere effektiv vier tage verzögerung die ich im im wert,
habe oder man kann es sogar als acht tage sehen aber mathematisch dass er den sagen den ehrenwert um vier tage verschieben mache ich dann noch eine wöchentliche durchschnittsbild und komm nochmal dreieinhalb tage verschiebung dazu so
das heißt ich laufe jetzt mit meinem
wert siebzehn achtzehn zwanzig tage hinter dem
tatsächlich ein datum wann das virus so erfolgreich war oder weniger erfolgreich war laufe ich halt zeitlich hinterher.
Dann nicht nur also für ist nicht nur die zehn halb,
tage verzögerung sondern für eine zuverlässige erbe rechnung für den tag an den stattgefunden hat sind es halt,
siebzehn achtzehn neunzehn tage bis ich das jenachdem wie man da da mittelt so und das macht's
macht's natürlich auch ganz ganz schwierig und deswegen versucht halt das mit dem cast das ganze zu verkürzen aber das gelingt bei sondergrößen zeit einfach auch nicht
wirklich ja es kann können auch keine wunder vollbringen.
Auch wenn sie eigentlich näher dran sein müssten und insofern wenn sie heute in der pressekonferenz davon geredet haben.
Der liegt,
jetzt bei null komma neun sechs gerundet eins was meinen sie jetzt mit jetzt,
sie können auch nicht nicht mehr als fünf tage schneller sein oder eigentlich statistisch gesehen drei vier tage können sie halt mit dem cast das ganze vielleicht.
Früher detektieren aber.
Wir reden hier von siebzehn tagen so wenn sie jetzt also von einem von eins jetzt reden kann nicht der zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gemeint sein mit irgendeiner auch nur
annähernd akzeptablen fehlertoleranz also bei den siebzehn tagen würde die zwischen keine ahnung kann es zwischen null komma drei und eins komma fünf alles sein meiner meinung nach so und
was ich nachvollziehen kann also beim mit meinen rechnungen die vor osterwoche lagen wir bei null komma acht.
Produktionszeit basierend.
Wie lange ist das jetzt her also gestern finde ich immer so ein bisschen schwer zu greifen.
Das ist jetzt drei wochen her und sind jetzt eins zwei,
drei wochen also vor vor rund drei wochen um den zwölften vierten herum also vor dem zehnten vor dem zehnten zwölften vierten ähm.
Also vor drei wochen vor ostern.
Genau lagen wir wie gesagt bei null komma acht und wo wir heute liegen
meiner meinung nach nicht weit davon weg aber ich kann's halt genauso wenig vorhersagen wie das so obwohl sie irgendwie,
das problem so ein bisschen den eindruck erwecken jetzt als könnten sie das gerade weil sie von r liegt gerade aktuell bei eins reden.
Oder null komma sechs und das finde ich schwierig aber das was mir dann.
Nachdem ich dann,
mir alle funktionen eingebaut hatte in den in den grafen um zum einen auch für die zahl der toten berechnen zu können,
also denselben algorithmus einfach auf die zahl der toten anzuwenden und gleichzeitig meine kurven schön verschieben zu können.
Und da habe ich dann versucht so mal ein bild und es lohnt sich sich das vielleicht anzuschauen.
Das packen wir in die shownotes.
Link.
Und dieses eine bild fast halt sehr gut zusammen wie ich aus den zahlen oder.
Ja konstruieren konnte wann sich eigentlich was bisher abgespielt hat mit r und mit den infektionen und mit den
leuten die sich tödlich infiziert haben also alle diese zahlen alle diese kurven irgendwie in einklang zu bringen und so zu verschieben dass sie alle tagesgeld infektionen
ereignisse wiedergeben also wie viele leute haben sich infiziert an einem tag wie viel
leute haben sich infiziert an dem tag die dann anschließend gestorben sind und wie lag
an diesem tag wie erfolgreich war der virus an diesem,
tag bei seiner fortpflanzung oder beim bei seiner neuen ansteckung und wenn man sich dann.
All diese dinge anguckt dann.
Stellt man fest dass er wie wir das auch schon in den letzten sendungen gesagt haben tatsächlich sehr früh schon begonnen hat zu fallen tatsächlich war jetzt,
zahlen nachgibt,
wahrscheinlich auf dem höhepunkt kurz nach der zweiten februar hälfte also noch nicht also er hat sozusagen schon ende februar anfang märz lang war er,
im fallen begriffen als hier noch nicht mal panik so richtig war oder die.
Vorsicht vorsicht.
Es ging gerade es es ging genau es ging gerade.
Italien und so weiter berichte es wohl auf einmal ein thema war in den news und.
Aber es gab noch club es gab noch klopapier weil das war dann genau die woche wo dann das klopapier plötzlich ausverkauft also es ging alles auf einmal ganz schnell.
Bis dann am neunten märz
so die ersten maßnahmen kam war er schon je nachdem welche beiden ob ich jetzt die kurve der toten oder die andere erwartet sag mal auf
rund eins komma fünf schon gefallen von dem war nicht mehr so dieses dieses komplett freie ausbreiten wie es wahrscheinlich vorher der fall war obwohl sagen werden ja.
Da gab es jetzt durch ausweiten von tests auch vielleicht übertriebene wachstums so ja aber wir reden hier von zahlen und auch von vorhersage zahlen die halt einfach zueinander passen und.
Beladen bei eins komma fünf ungefähr so also zwischen.
Eins und eins komma sechs eins komma zwei bis eins komma sechs zu dem zeitpunkt neunte märz als.
So die ersten.
Maßnahmen eingeführt worden das war noch nicht die schulschließungen die kamen dann am sechzehnten märz und da.
Geht jetzt aus,
meiner verschobenen grafiker vor das am sechzehnten märz immer noch knapp über eins lagen so bei eins komma eins eins komma zwei und.
Das und er war zwar zu dem zeitpunkt auch im sinken begriffen noch und wäre möglicherweise auch weiter gesunken.
Aber am ende waren's dann wohl die maßnahmen dann doch vom dreiundzwanzigsten also die ausgangssperren die das ganze deutlich unter eins gezogen haben eben auf die
wo es dann ungefähr zwei wochen lang jetzt verblieben ist bis
eben vor ostern und wie sich dann weiterentwickelt hat wissen wir noch nicht ja das ist sozusagen die eine.
Erkenntnis aus diesem verschobenen grafen die andere ist aber dass.
Fallendes mal auch jetzt nicht so ernst nehmen darf oder dass halt eben so lange es über eins ist hat das eigentlich,
kaum eine bedeutung außer die kurve tatsächlich dann schon abzuflachen also wir haben sozusagen flatternde curve schon seit.
Eigentlich seit dem dreiundzwanzigsten zwoten flatten wir die kurve.
Aber die körper halt extrem unfälle gewesen wenn wir sie nicht auch wirklich nachhaltig geplättet hätten.
Aber die sozusagen die meisten haben sich angesteckt nachdem sie geflattert war
die kurve kann sagen zwei drittel haben sich nach dem sechzehnten märz angesteckt so über die hälfte
so oder hat sich angesteckt nach der ausgangssperre am dreiundzwanzigsten ja wo er dann schon unter.
Null und eins unter eins war weil einfach.
Viele infizierte schon da waren dann.
Es sind einfach viele infizierte da und bei einem von null komma acht.
Ja stecken halt zehn infizierte immer noch acht neue an das heißt dass man ja seitdem.
Seit den ausgangssperren haben sich halt die hälfte hat sich halt nochmal so viel leute angesteckt wie vor den ausgangssperren.
Ich finde ich finde deine grafik ist es wie gesagt ein bisschen schwierig das jetzt im podcast zu machen das bild wenn wir auch nochmal etwas annotiert mit in die shownotes packen schaut da mal mit
drauf ist jetzt allerdings nicht ganz so wichtig was ich allerdings wie bist du denn überhaupt drauf gekommen weil
so eine grafik habe ich jetzt bisher noch gar nicht gesehen weil das ist ja du hast ja im prinzip einen komplett was heißt neu also.
Auf jeden fall ein parameter den ich so jetzt noch nicht gesehen habe du hast,
okay neue infizierte das sehen wir am laufenden meter sehen wir seit anfang an ne also es ist so die infektion gehen hoch und so weiter also nicht wie viel sind es insgesamt sondern wie viele infizieren sich neu das,
hat man schon mal gesehen da sind wir natürlich auch die todesrisiko hatten die dann aber immer so in der zeit nach läufig sind,
was du ja gemacht hast und was ich eigentlich ganz pfiffig finde ist was quasi.
Neu infektion nochmal eine zweite zahl daneben gestellt und diese zweite zahl sind.
Auch neue infektionen aber halt die der anteil von diesem neuinfektionen die an sich aufgetreten sind die dann später auch tödlich verlaufen.
Und das ist das ist wirklich ganz interessant das heißt die laufen auch mehr oder weniger in derselben kurve nur die tödliche ist halt abgeschwächt.
Ja na ja wie gesagt.
Wie das zeitliche verhältnis untereinander ist da gibt es einen gewissen spielraum da kann man annahmen treffen so ich habe
verschiedene szenarien durchgespielt und durchgerechnet und bin dann aber für das was ich dort jetzt habe ist das plausibel ste weil was halt die
trotzdem relativ verschieben kann ist wenn sich jetzt natürlich das virus in.
Population ausbreitet also alte leute altersheime und so weiter dann könnte das natürlich auch eine eine verschiebung sagen dieser dieser kurve bewirken oder dieser beiden kurven,
gegeneinander aber so ich bin in zu dem schluss gekommen dass das für diesen betrachteten zeitraum,
eher nicht der fall war oder nicht in einem erheblichen umfang zu einer zeitlichen verschiebung geführt hat sondern dass die schon annähernd proportional.
Verlaufen
die zahl der tödlichen ansteckungen und die die zahl der gemeldeten ansteckung also nicht proportional genau aber lang schon dass der gipfel,
der tödlichen ansteckungen und der ansteckungen überhaupt tendenziell ziemlich nah beieinander liegen innerhalb von ein bis zwei tagen oder so.
Das ist eine annahme die getroffen wurde plus eben das ganze,
halt auch noch plausibilisieren mit den ganzen zahlen aus dem steckbrief wie lange dauert es im schnitt von ansteckung bis erkrankung und bis intensivstation es gibt leider nicht die eine zahl bei denen,
wo sie sagen das ist die solange dauert es im durchschnitt von infektion bis jemand verstirbt wenn er verstirbt.
Das ist auch mal schwer weil die zahlen sich hinterher läuft es sterben nicht also kannst wie immer genau sagen.
Letztlich alle verstorben sind oder vielleicht dann sechzig tage später oder so hast du das dann dann komplett weil die halt langsam ausläuft aber für mich lagen da eben,
diese verschiedenen wichtigen erkenntnisse erstens hat sehr früh begonnen zu fallen aber es,
hätte nicht ausgereicht nichts zu tun so das kann man definitiv auch sagen.
Will ich auch nochmal kurz mit meinen worten zusammenfassen weil das war ja auch in der letzten woche wirklich inhalt der debatte und natürlich auch für so die ganzen verschwörungstheoretikern auch wieder so ein futter ne man hat halt diese grafiken gesehen aus denen sich entnehmen lässt.
Fällt ja massiv und das tat es schon bevor maßnahmen ergriffen wurden,
ergo so die schlussfolgerung die einfache das war ja unnötig dass das so ein bisschen dass das dass das meter thema gewesen in der letzten woche und was sieht man jetzt aus seiner grafik sehr schön herauslesen kann ist.
Ja er ist gefallen.
Er ist an der stelle nicht der entscheidende faktor das ist zwar so die zahl für die zukunft die wollen wir halt runterbringen und wenn wir das nicht tun werden die infektion wieder zunehmen nur
zu dem zeitpunkt als uns das alles
aufgefallen ist es ist losging und wir so alle so langsam die corona panik bekommen haben und so dieses ok das ist jetzt ein thema für uns dann,
da passiert was ja hat also allein schon diese schock reaktion zwar schon zur änderung geführt.
Die so einen ehrenwert halt schnell drücken aber solange der über eins ist.
Ist es gefährlich und dadurch dass er vorher halt nicht unter eins war sondern eben das muss ich mal kurz gucken mitte februar ungefähr so bei was war das.
Sich jetzt ehrlich gesagt hier gerade nicht also sehr viel höher lag drei genau.
In der gegend von drei.
So da sind sehr viele leute infiziert worden und die waren ja dann in der welt.
Und die haben dann eben andere leute infiziert und das sieht man halt hier sehr schön an dieser grafik das heißt sommer zu betonen.
Die drei maßnahmen.
Neunter märz sechzehnter märz dreiundzwanzigster märz schon bei der ersten maßnahme rauscht die zahl der neu infizierten nach oben richtig.
Beat und es ist irgendwie,
man sieht so richtig wie dann jede weitere maßnahme also die vom sechzehnten und dann auch nochmal die vom dreiundzwanzigsten quasi dieses ding so nach unten zieht und sagt halt stopp,
wir müssen dich in griff kriegen.
Also selbst wenn er niedrig ist schlicht die zahl der leute die bereits infiziert waren hätten einfach dann dafür gesorgt dass wir einfach zu erheblichen zahlen gekommen sind sprich hätte es diese maßnahmen nicht gegeben werden wir jetzt
weil sie nicht in.
Tatsächlich ich habe unten ist noch so eine magenta kurve drin die ich auch auf twitter nicht erwähnt oder erläutert habe die.
Das ist nochmal die ableitung von der zunahme der infizierten kurve und da sieht man dass die zunahme tatsächlich am höchsten war nach dem neunten
märz also am zehnten ungefähr um den zehnten rum also schon sozusagen nach den ersten
maßnahmen die zudem zeitpunkt gewirkt haben schon hatten wir aber die größte zunahme zu verzeichnen.
So an infektionen so das heißt obwohl das virus weniger erfolgreich war so pro
im leute anstecken also jeder einzelne war aber die zahl der infizierten mittlerweile zu dem zeitpunkt so hoch dass sagen der rückgang von von r einfach dem,
wachstum dem immer noch stattfinden nicht wirklich einhalt gebieten konnte sondern das bestenfalls
etwas verlangsamt weil sie in anstieg verlangsamen aber nicht irgendwie den anstieg bremsen können sondern das ist dann erst vierzehn tage später wirklich passiert.
Ja ist die frage was lernen wir da jetzt daraus außer.
Die maßnahmen haben gewirkt weil ihr die große frage ist natürlich jetzt.
Was jetzt was also wie lange muss jetzt die wie lange müssen wir die maßnahmen noch anhalten jetzt haben wir diese ganze lockerung debatte natürlich bereit und ist ja auch alles sehr nachvollziehbar die leute haben jetzt so ein bisschen schnauze voll.
Es riecht nicht nach bedrohung.
Also man merkt das so so virus war da was so ich ich sehe kein virus und.
Die zahlen sind schwer zu interpretieren und natürlich möchten alle gerne wieder zurück zu einem business wenn auch nicht.
Stellt sich halt jetzt die frage was was liest du aus diesen zahlen jetzt raus.
Immer mal diese diese belastung der wirtschaft und vielleicht auch die.
Psychologische belastung der gesellschaft nur so für einen kurzen moment raus sag mal einfach mal so wir könnten jetzt beliebig so weitermachen.
Wenn man einfach weiter lok down macht so ja geil super endlich mal wieder backen und so ne wie weit würdest du es dann treiben.
Um auf welchen wert zu kommen um zu sagen jetzt sind wir aber auch sicher unter diesem geforderten.
Tausend neuinfektionen pro tag oder weniger die das gesagt hat.
Also wir müssten eigentlich schon in der nächsten woche.
Unter die tausend kommen in der wochenspiegel so also,
dürften die tausend nächste woche nicht mehr überschreiten diese woche wird's
nochmal ich meine heute waren wir bei elf vierundvierzig und es gibt wahrscheinlich dann morgen nochmal ein bisschen runter und dann wieder nochmal ein bisschen rauf so aber dann,
spätestens so ab nächsten montag sollten wir unter.
Den tausend bleiben deutlich also unter neunhundert eigentlich in der in der in der woche.
So das wäre dann sagen theoretisch die zahl bei der wir angeblich das ganze.
Die gesundheitsämtern angeblich diese zahl von neuinfektionen auch tatsächlich tracken können.
Tatsächlich haben wir ja dort wiederum die
die zeitverschiebung drin das heißt wenn man das jetzt wieder zeit verschoben betrachtet müssten wir eigentlich längst schon oder jetzt
bereits schon den punkt erreicht haben also heute am heutigen tag oder in dieser woche sollten tatsächlich keine tausend neuinfektionen mehr stattgefunden haben auch wenn,
für sie halt jetzt berichten so das heißt theoretisch wenn die tausend die zahl sind dann sind die tausend erreicht,
so diese woche wenn er jetzt gemeint hat okay tausend mit,
vierzehn tagen oder mit zehn tagen verspätung dann nächste woche.
Also eine woche noch richtig durchhalten wer angesagt aber wenn wir natürlich jetzt nicht tun weil die lockerung sind ja jetzt da.
Wenn auch nicht im großen maße dafür kommen ja aber auch neue sachen dazu also dieses gesichtsmasken tragen n v und den supermärkten ist jetzt seit heute auch in berlin entsprechend angesagt also gilt jetzt ab
mittwoch wenn diese sendung hier rauskommt aber das ist sozusagen jetzt auch.
Beschlossen und von daher wird das verhalten anders an als vorher muss man schauen was das bringt.
Also die ersten anzeichen werden wir so ja.
Auch in der übernächsten woche sehen erst.
Die lockerungen oder auch lockerungen der selbstdisziplin die ja auch vielfach zu beobachten waren ob denen haben oder nicht wenn wir nächste woche noch nicht wissen.
Sondern erst übernächste woche so werden wir da tatsächlich was zu sagen können und.
Eigentlich eher erst in vierzehn tagen aussagen über beziehungsweise in drei wochen ja.
Aussagen über machen können wie sich denn jetzt tatsächlich verändert hat in der letzten ja heute.
Und in vierzehn tagen in der wie sich innerhalb der letzten woche wo ja schon lang dinge ja ihre schatten voraus geworfen haben man gesehen hat verkehr war mehr und,
mehr leute auf den straßen und so.
Also wir bleiben noch zwei wochen.
Also zwei also die nächsten zwei wochen denke ich lohnt sich sendungen auf jeden fall noch.
Auch ja ja also meine ich muss zugeben klar ist natürlich jetzt schade veranstaltung hätte sicherlich zahlreiche gegeben das wetter ist schön und so weiter werden alle andere planungen gar keine frage aber.
Mich also für mich macht es ja sozusagen keinen großen unterschied jetzt in meinem.
Persönlichen arbeitsleben ich kann meine podcast hier einfach genauso weitermachen und halt mich einfach so aus dem sonstigen leben raus das geht natürlich jetzt.
Weil die meisten leuten natürlich nicht so gar keine frage der stelle auch im privileg aber ich versuche mich halt auch zurückzuhalten also das ist das was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ich,
bin relativ vorsichtig geworden so supermärkte et cetera findet es auch ganz gut jetzt mit der masken- pflicht weil das einfach.
Dass das nimmt das nimmt dann auch so ein stress raus auch mitbekommen dass viele leute extrem stresst im supermarkt zu sein weil wir jetzt einfach so.
Ihr gänge zu vermeiden irgendwie wo leute drin sind und irgendwie ja.
So was sagt uns das jetzt so für die nähere zukunft alles.
Also der längerfristige ausblick also wann ist das eigentlich jetzt zu ende so ist ja immer die frage hat sich,
eigentlich bei mir seit märz nicht geändert ich müsste mal die tickets raussuchen in denen ich gesagt hab also im juni ist alles vorbei so,
natürlich ist nicht alles vorbei im juni aber wir werden wahrscheinlich im juni auf jeden fall das gefühl haben dass es erstmal vorbei ist.
Ich denke es wird.
Ja auf der welt wahrscheinlich auch nochmal unterschiedlich aber es wird sehr wahrscheinlich im laufe des mai so mitte ende mai plötzlich während die zahlen,
wahrscheinlich so niedrig sein dass wir plötzlich alle ganz entspannt sind wahrscheinlich zu entspannt weil dann kommt's kommt's wieder aber und dann braucht es natürlich seine zeit
auch jetzt internationale regelungen wie ist es mit dem reiseverkehr so wann,
machen die länder ihre grenzen wieder auf und ich habe da jetzt keine insider informationen aber meine prognose ist auch das sagen wir
irgendwann im laufe des juni
grenzöffnung sehen werden vielleicht sogar auch schon früher bei einigen ländern wo die wo die zahlen.
Richtig gut sind also bei beiden ländern man dann mehr reiseverkehr zulassen wird.
Auf tourismus wird es allerdings nicht viel hinauslaufen also zumindest kein internationalen tourismus denke wenn wir relativ glücklich sind und wenn auch die deutsche tourismusindustrie glücklich ist dann dann dann wird es zu einem erhöhten innerdeutschen reiseverkehr kommen.
Aber so urlaub in spanien und in italien kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt jetzt hat noch nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Ja vielleicht nicht im juni aber juli august sehe ich da durchaus,
chancen auch wenn viele aus der momentan sicht noch sagen oh mein gott so wie könnt ihr nur an sowas denken mein,
gefühl jetzt sagt mir.
Der sommer nicht völlig verloren ist auch wenn ich nach wie vor schwarz sehe für jetzt große events und so
alles auf einem reduzierten niveau stattfinden wird und jetzt nicht plötzlich wir schon touristen
zahlen und ströme haben werden wie vor korona das gewiss nicht aber
ich rechne ehrlich gesagt schon damit dass wir.
Im sommer noch tourismus sehen werden ich will jetzt keine nicht nicht zu sehr erwartungen schüren und ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ob das wirklich.
Gut und richtig sein wird und ob ich dann auch
sagen verreisen werde aber ich glaube das hat sich bei vielen erstens dein bedürfnis angestaut sagen sowohl bei der in der nachfrage
als auch bei natürlich in der gastronomie und in der luftfahrt und überall und wie gesagt ob das jetzt für die.
Aus biologischer sicht sind sinnvoll ist weiß ich nicht aber den zahlen nach so wenn man den
jetzt nur auf die zahlen guckt wenn sie sich jetzt durch werden wir durch durch zu frühes
aufmachen jetzt nicht die zahlen wieder zu früh nach oben treiben dann könnte uns nochmal so einen,
ein monat shutdown oder so so ein zwischenstatus down vom herbst nochmal drohen wenn das passiert aber er.
Dass die zahlen dann plötzlich im im juni auf einmal sich viele fragen werden corona was war das.
Derzeit noch nicht so richtig vorstellbar aber der mensch vergisst natürlich auch schnell dass das stimmt natürlich.
Ja ansonsten bin ich noch auf eine seite aufmerksam gemacht worden aus singapur so gut die wollen jetzt ein bisschen groß.
Angepriesen mit irgendeiner ki die da werkelt aber tatsächlich machen sie einfach auch einfach einen sinn
model fitting aber machen das halt sehr schön weil sie werfen halt zwei werte aus nämlich wann zu siebenundneunzig prozent,
man durch ist mit den infizierten und wann man zu hundert prozent durch ist.
Aufgespalten nach ja nach aufgespalten nach ländern.
Nach ländern und die gesamte welt wobei man natürlich auch berücksichtigen muss das sind jetzt auch nur vorhersagen die jetzt änderungen,
in und so auch nur bedingt vorher oder nicht wirklich vorhersagen können oder verhaltensänderungen oder andere dinge sondern auch nur.
Auf den rhein zahlen bisher basieren und versuchen dann das auf das modell anzupassen aber nichtsdestotrotz finde ich diese beiden werte auch wenn's eine momentaufnahme von heute ist
doch doch sehr hilfreich und
um es mal für deutschland jetzt zu sagen zu siebenundneunzig prozent sind wir am dritten mai durch und zu hundert prozent am sechsten juni,
dieser seite und das ist jetzt auch nicht halte ich jetzt nicht für.
Völlig absurd so diese diese zahlen
für die gesamte welt ist es auch nochmal ausgerechnet da es so dass wir auch am dass wir am dreißigsten mai mit siebenundneunzig prozent durch sind aber mit hundert prozent erst am ersten dezember.
Weil es einfach viele da gibt die.
Die noch hinterher die hier noch hinterher hängen die noch hinterherlaufen und so sieht sehen halt die zahlen.
Einfach dort aus ja und weil wir es ja gerade hatten für das thema dann
urlaub also italien neunte mai siebenundneunzig prozent also ist auch hat in vierzehn tagen sozusagen das
in vierzehn tagen weitestgehend durch und aber auch hundert prozent ende erst am einunddreißigsten august
das heißt das schleppt sich da noch so ein bisschen.
Und spanien immerhin schon am zweiten august also eher spanien als italien im moment und sogar auch noch frankreich neunter august.
Also wenn ich das sehr natürlich viele länder die kann ich jetzt nicht alle komplett durchgehen aber zumindest ist deutschland jetzt hier in diesen herr vorgehobenen ländern so auf platz zwei da ist nur australien noch ein bisschen schneller.
Es gibt ganz unten am ende der seite gibt's nochmal so eine irgendwie numerische tabelle wobei das halt nach siebenundneunzig prozent ende irgendwie sortiert ist.
Neuseeland ist komischerweise gar nicht dabei ja.
Auch die sind durch die haben siebenundneunzig prozent am siebzehnten april.
Neunundneunzig prozent am fünfundzwanzigsten april tabelle ganz unten vierte von oben.
Am elften mai sollen sollte neuseeland irgendwie komplett durch sein ein monat vor uns.
Das wird interessant sein dass dann mal zu überprüfen wie denn das am ende dann auch wirklich gewesen sein wird.
Auf jeden fall wie gesagt ist eine momentaufnahme aber sie aktualisieren das ganze wohl laufend und insofern.
Auf jeden fall auch mal leute die sich dann mal einen konkreten vorhersagen versuchen.
Gut dann lass uns noch mal auf die ganze geschichte mit den tracing apps eingehen,
wir hatten ja hier vor zwei wochen das erste mal intensiv darüber gesprochen und ich habe in dem podcast das,
dezentrale modell vorgestellt was apple und google vorgeschlagen haben.
Und wir haben ja viel über die ganzen implikationen und wie das da genau läuft wer erzeugt wann wo welche etcetera kryptographie was ist alles dabei gesprochen
dann letzte woche haben wir dieses dezentrale modell durchgesprochen was diese forschungsgruppe pepp
tv oder dieses projekt per pdf in den raum gestellt hat und damals sah es ja auch noch so aus also damals gut na fühlt sich an wie da
damals letzte woche da hieß es ja dann auch das sei das favorisierte modell der.
Bundesregierung und das hat sich dann doch sehr schnell geändert es gab dann relativ große aufregung und so die ganzen datenschutz bewegten organisationen auch der c viele andere mehr um sich dann auch extrem klar positioniert haben gesagt so dieses modell
ist einfach mal nicht,
ok und ich denke das war ja auch so ein bisschen unsere schlussfolgerung dass da einfach viel zu viele unwegbarkeiten drin sind dass das modell an sich schon nicht sonderlich datenschutzfreundliche ist
aber vor allem auch sowas die konkret softwareentwicklung also was da alles für gebaut werden muss wie gut das funktionieren muss damit es ein versprechen noch halbwegs sicher zu sein erfüllen muss
dass das halt alles nicht sehr gut aussah naja jetzt die wände übers wochenende
bundesregierung sagt okay war es nur spaß wir machen dann doch mal dezentrales modell mit den entsprechenden stoßseufzer aus vielen
ecken die dir vielleicht so einen umschwung so schnell nicht erwartet haben aber wir lernen auch in dieser situation geht,
alles ein wenig schneller als man das üblicherweise gewohnt ist.
Ich werde jetzt erstmal nur mal festhalten was passiert ist also der zentrale ansatz ist jetzt tot du hast ja noch ein paar gedanken machen ich habe mir auch noch mal ein paar gedanken gemacht und mir vor allem darüber gedanken gemacht warum es eigentlich zu dieser auseinandersetzung so gekommen ist weil.
Es ist ja jetzt nicht so,
dass diese pepp leute irgendwie 'ne rudel überwachungs- würdiger menschen werden ja die jetzt hier eine infrastruktur bauen die danach maximal ausgenutzt werden können soll.
Sondern ich kann eigentlich nur allen unterstellen dass es eigentlich gut meinen.
Also die haben die haben darüber nachgedacht wie können wir dieses problem lösen die haben alle diese diese diese relativ nahe liegende geschichte mit dem bluetooth gesehen und sich darüber gedanken gemacht okay was,
können wir jetzt eigentlich tun und mich hat es am anfang so ein bisschen überrascht wie man auf dieses andere modell überhaupt kommen kann und ich bin dann,
willst dann später eingefallen was was wahrscheinlich hier das problem war in den köpfen und zwar.
Das gerade wir nerds wenn wir sozusagen über dieses contact tracing reden reden sehr über so einen technischen vorgang.
Und haben uns darüber eigentlich im wesentlichen gedanken gemacht während dieser anderen perspektive wahrscheinlich ein wenig mehr davon getragen war.
Was können wir jetzt hier maximal für die bekämpfung dieser krise.
Und die zeit danach herausholen und das sind halt zwei sachen die glaube ich in dieser ganzen debatte vermischt wurden.
Das eine ist dieses wie.
Kann dieses tracing stattfinden wie kann man diese tätigkeit die derzeit halt manuell gemacht wird.
Elektronisch unterstützt werden unter ausnutzung eben dieser realität dass sehr viele leute nicht alle aber sehr viele leute mit ihren bluetooth telefon durch die gegend laufen und.
Das unterstützt ja diesen prozess oder es hat das potenzial diesen prozess der manuellen des manuellen dressings das irgendwie,
zu verbessern dass das ist sozusagen das eine versprechen was in dieser ganzen geschichte drin steckt ob das später erfüllt werden wird.
Ganz andere debatte aber das ist das versprechen das haben alle gesehen darüber haben sich alle gedanken gemacht zweite überlegung ist natürlich.
Was können wir aber während man so etwas macht vielleicht noch ein zusätzlichen informationen generieren was all diese ganzen modelle berechnungen planung.
Einschätzung das was wir jetzt im prinzip die erste stunde hier über schon wieder diskutiert haben dieses zahlenmaterial welche parameter fließen da ein wie kann man das bewerten wir kriegen wir stabilere ergebnisse wie können wir besser in die zukunft schauen wie können wir auch schneller reagieren
also der nutzen von so etwas aus einer.
Videolog perspektive und dieses ganze zentrale modell was wir besprochen haben,
atmet eigentlich diesen gedanken durch.
Dass man eben eier ok kontakt wurde festgestellt jetzt schnell her mit den daten und zwar wir wollen irgendwas haben was wir sofort
berechnen können wo wir sofort grafen haben wo wir irgendwie in die zukunft blicken können und ich verstehe diesen wunsch
aber das dieser wunsch und der andere wunsch in einen topf gerührt wurde,
das hat dann eben dazu geführt dass man softair modell letzten endes an die tafel gemalt hat was eben all diese ganzen schwierigkeiten hat,
die letzte mal schon so ausführlich besprochen haben einerseits die unmöglichkeit der technischen durchführung unter bestimmten bedingungen sprich apple hat
dicht gemacht man man man kann das so gar nicht ohne weiteres durchführen aber dann eben diese ganze verlagerung der daten in die cloud die dort verwaltet werden die dort geschützt werden müssen die komplexität der software die erhöhte angreifbar all diese ganzen sachen
das hat man sich damit eben
auch verkauft und ich glaube das wurde dann auch am anfang noch nicht so sehr als problem gesehen weil man eben lösungsorientiert sein wollte weil man irgendwie sagt naja okay wie wie wie können wir das alles zusammenrühren.
Und deswegen ist es glaube ich sehr wertvoll dass man das trennt ich habe dann auch nochmal einen längeren tweets zu abgesetzt und dann war es ein tag später ja dann auch schon durch diese debatte.
Jetzt sind wir also auf jeden fall in der situation dass wir ein dezentrales modell haben und.
Da ist jetzt meiner meinung nach noch so ein bisschen offen welche projektgruppen jetzt hier wirklich so durchziehen aber so mein gefühl ist dass diese gruppe die sich aus diesem projekt heraus getrennt hat dieses de
modell was ja auch in der schweiz jetzt umgesetzt wird dass das im wesentlichen der kern der entwicklung sein wird.
Dieses.
Die drei p t projekt verfolgt jetzt eigentlich im wesentlichen dieselbe idee wie dieses apple google protokoll also apple und google haben ja eigentlich auch nur gesagt ok wenn ihr dressing machen wollt auf unseren telefon dann können wir das so und so unterstützen.
Hier ist unser vorschlag wie ihr das machen könnt und da könnt ihr euch dann an das heißt,
für die nächste zukunft ist vor allem die frage was macht die app so was,
was wird die jetzt tun und wie wird sie vor allem auch mit dieser mit diesem verlust.
Diesem scheinbaren verlust demo logischer informationsgeber umgehen und wie kann man das kompensieren.
Sollten wir jetzt im nachgang auch nochmal diskutieren.
Jetzt ist aber auch nicht so dass apple und google jetzt sich einfach zurückgelegt haben und gesagt haben ja okay alles klar wir haben jetzt mal hier unseren punkt gemacht jetzt bauen wir mal wieder i phone,
wir haben auch noch andere sachen zu tun und müssen ja irgendwie unsere welt revolution ausrollen dein nein man kann davon ausgehen,
bei denen hat die hütte richtig gebrannt nicht nur weil er die ganze zeit irgendwelche staatenlenker angerufen haben gesagt haben nee nee wir brauchen das aber hier mal mit voller überwachung und so weiter was erlaube apple und
könnt ihr mal bitte mal alles einschalten wir sind auch hier die nation und so wie ich das mitbekommen habe hat sich apple halt einfach also ich sage jetzt
klar die gehen jetzt hand in hand damit google und ich denke mal die sind da da sind die reihen auch geschlossen aber es ist ja auch klar dass es vor allem die.
Technische realität so wie sie im apple ökosystem gerade ist.
Die eigentliche barriere ist und mir war eigentlich von anfang an klar apple wird sich da einfach kein jota wegbewegen zumindest nicht in dem bereich wo es kritisch ist.
Genau und der der der punkt aber warum sich apple und google.
Nicht bewegen ich weiß nicht ob wir das beim letzten mal schon rausgearbeitet haben ist es ist nicht so weil sie irgendwelche idealisten wären oder irgendwie staatsfeinden oder keine ahnung
deutschland und frankreich ärgern wollen oder so sondern sie können einfach schlichtweg nicht.
Ohne ihrem eigenen geschäft und ihrer eigenen marke massiven schaden,
zuzufügen das ist einfach der punkt das wäre für die beiden ruinösen weil halt denen im gegensatz zu offensichtlich aber den
anderen gutmeinenden kräften die diese zentrale lösung gepusht haben was dir nicht klarer ist
der trend geht eigentlich seit längerem hin zu mehr privatsphäre mehr kontrolle übers
eigene gerät aus gutem grund wurden ja irgendwie die permission immer weiter verfeinert auf den auf den handys ist ja nicht so dass das irgendwie die das gemacht haben weil sie gerne knöpfe ein
bauen und irgendwie mich durch mehr reifen hüpfen lassen wollen dass sich die kamera und das mikrofon einzeln freigeben und die
und den zugriff auf skepsis einzeln freigeben und aufs fotoalbum und dies und jenes so auf auf die nachrichten nee das ist halt
ganz ganz wichtig einfach auch für die sicherheit und akzeptanz dieser geräte so und da kann man nicht entgegen dem lang.
Trend der langsam und schwierig genug ist jetzt nicht irgendwie plötzlich wieder irgendwas einbauen was diesen trend umkehrt so das geht einfach nicht das ist einfach nicht,
das ist unmöglich und ich kenne halt aber auch also mich hatte auch als als ich zum ersten mal von dem.
Tracing per bluetooth die rede war als das so durch die medien ging habe ich
in meinem umfeld von ganz vielen leuten wo ich gar nicht wusste dass sie sich irgendwie jetzt um sowas einen kopf machen gehört ja irgendwie aber was die wollen jetzt irgendwie mich treffen so und meine position tracken und meine kontakte treffen das hat,
bei vielen leuten ganz unmittelbar unbehagen hervorgerufen gar nicht also auch,
ob zurecht oder zu unrecht aber man hat festgestellt ihr zurecht
so aber das habe ich sonst also das hatte ich nicht erwartet dass sagen dass das doch bei so vielen leuten auf unbehagen stößt
trotz der ganzen korona und tracking und eigentlich ja nur für einen guten zweck aber er war dann ganz schnell irgendwie nie eigentlich
geht es niemanden an mit wem ich mich treffe.
Da ändert sich das bewusstsein man merkt das einfach ne also im prinzip sind sind die unternehmen da auch derzeit schon so ein bisschen voraus die riechen den braten die sehen auf der einen seite es gibt eine größeres aus nutzungs- in größere ausnutzung bereitschaft bei
starten bei firmen bei kriminellen ohnehin also alles was ich in irgendeiner form pfeil bietet als.
Als potenzielles angriffsziel wird auch angegriffen werden das ist das eine da machen sie einfach zu aber sie sehen auch dass die,
menschheit an sich das ist ja wirklich ein mega globaler markt in den einen ländern mehr in den anderen weniger die leute sich hinzunehmen den maße auch bewusst werden dass das so ist.
Der trend geht da ganz klar hin und wenn sie jetzt auch einfach gesagt hätten so ach ja krise klar na dann machen wir jetzt hier einfach schotten auf kein problem
sind ja nur die guten staaten und ist ja für einen guten zweck kein problem hier tore auf los geht's das wäre ein ein ein riesiger
gesichtsverlust und vertrauensverlust gewesen den sie natürlich wie du schon richtig sagt ist so nicht mitgegangen werden und von daher war es eine
sehr nur vierte eine sehr nur vierte antwort auf diese problematik
schnell auch also muss man sagen sie haben sich schnell mit dieser problematik beschäftigt und sie haben sich auch das haben wir ja hier vor zwei wochen ganz gut rausgestellt in ihrem ersten entwurf.
Eigentlich auch technisch schon gut positioniert also man sieht diesen protokoll was sie vorgeschlagen haben
an dass ihnen das alles bewusst ist sie sehen okay wir haben da eine chance wir müssen uns in gewisser hinsicht auch ein bisschen öffnen
aber wir sagen euch mal wir haben uns da schon so viel drüber nachgedacht und das ist ein thema was mit dem wir uns schon seit langer langer zeit sehr intensiv und eigentlich auch täglicher basis beschäftigen.
Das hier ist das einzige was wir tun können das ist unserer meinung nach die balance und mehr.
Gibt's jetzt erstmal im wesentlichen nicht daran werden wir jetzt arbeiten und ich glaube das ist den staaten und vielen projektteilnehmer nicht klar gewesen dass das eigentlich schon so das letzte angebot ist.
So und jetzt haben und google eine neue version dieses protokoll rausgebracht also dieses.
Contact tracing dieser contact tracing service den sie vorgestellt hatten vor einigen wochen.
In version eins null wurde er hatte noch gar keine version das war so der der erste aufschlag hat jetzt eine richtige versionen bekommen heißt version.
Eins punkt eins und sie haben diese spezifikation aktualisiert sie haben sie
teilweise ausführlicher gemacht sie haben den ganzen auch noch ein hinzu gestellt was auch ganz hilfreich ist ich finde es gibt immer noch so ein paar bereiche wo erklärungsbedarf ist aber es ist
man merkt sofort was alles auf sie all alles eingeflogen ist und sie haben zugesehen dass sie versuchen diese darstellung klarer zu machen.
Außerdem und das klappt ganz gut in das was ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe rein haben sie das protokoll.
Umbenannt wo sie vorher von contact tracing gesprochen haben und das ist.
Technisch gesehen ja auch der richtige begriff eigentlich.
Haben sie das ganze jetzt in export notification umbenannt das heißt sie sagen.
Man erhält eine benachrichtigung wenn man sich auf eine bestimmte art und weise exponiert hat also wenn man.
Sich in eine situation begeben hat in der man hätte infiziert werden können.
Und das ist eine ganz interessante umbenennung finde ich weil sie klar machen welche dienstleistung sie jetzt eigentlich gedenken hier anzubieten.
Das ist nicht so sehr um diese nachverfolgen an sich geht sondern dass sie schon.
Im rahmen des contact das ist ja auch der begriff für das was die gesundheitsämtern tun einen einen einen dienst anbieten aber dass der,
eigentliche dienst hier nur ein teil davon ist und dass sie eigentlich nur diese benachrichtigung von leuten die sich hier irgendwie dem virus gegenüber exponiert haben.
Leisten wollen finde ich 'ne interessante interessante variante die sie hier gewählt haben.
Technisch ist natürlich an sich alles gleich also es hat sich an dem modell was wir hier vor zwei wochen besprochen haben hat sich nichts geändert haben sie noch so ein paar andere kleine feinheiten geändert also zum beispiel in diesem protokoll.
Was ich sehr so an diesem ganzen realitäten von bluetooth orientiert etcetera,
gab so ein so ein ablauf schema wo man dann gesehen hat wie sich das so welche seite sendet welcher seite welche informationen zu welchem zeitpunkt relativ typisch für solche netzwerk protokolle.
Da gab's ja so eine so ein bereich der stand etwas.
Ja und wir wissen natürlich wenn man sich mit netzwerktechnik ein bisschen beschäftigt das ist ein stinknormaler standard begriff und steht in der bluetooths spezifikation überall drin,
und bedeutet halt nichts anderes als dass man in einem netzwerk dienst wenn man ein dienst anzubieten hat den halt bewirbt,
ja also man sagt hallo hier dienst und das heißt halt einfach wird es mit aber es haben natürlich diverse leute habt ihr auf twitter ein paar leute getroffen die so ja das steht ja überall mit drin was und haben natürlich sofort diese assoziation mit,
werbung gehabt und wussten irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr ein und aus das haben sie halt jetzt umbenannt an den stellen wo es möglich war also da wo sich
konkret auf dieses bluetooth adwords mit bezieht,
heißt es natürlich noch so aber ansonsten innerhalb ihres protokoll sprechen sie jetzt von broadcast damit irgendwie klar ist was hier gemeint ist das hier einfach nur was ausgesendet wird ne das ist schon ganz lustig,
so aber was hat sich denn jetzt eigentlich tatsächlich geändert also ich sagte ja schon im wesentlichen hat sich an diesem protokoll nichts geändert aber sie haben ein paar sachen.
Eingebaut die ganz sinnvoll sind und das betrifft einerseits die daten die konkret von einem telefon zum anderen übermittelt werden.
Und andererseits die kryptographie die sich in diesem ganzen spiel
abspielt das mit der kryptographie hat im wesentlichen so performance gründe gehabt aber das mit den daten ist ganz interessant
bisher war es ja so über diese ganzen kryptischen graphischen protokolle wird halt am laufenden meter immer wieder so ein neuer schlüssel ausgeworfen und.
Daraus ergeben sich diese all dies die letzten endes wirklich versendet werden und bisher in der ursprünglichen version des protokolle war es eben auch nur diese.
Die von einem telefon zum anderen wandelte jetzt kommen noch daten dazu und zwar einerseits immer sehr sinnvoll bei solchen protokollen eine version nummer.
Typischerweise in eine major und meiner version also wenn das halt jetzt das
in der version eins punkt eins ist dann ist halt die major version eins und die meiner version ist eins und das steht dann halt mit in dem paket auch drin damit wenn halt irgendwie nochmal ein,
visions wechsel stattfindet in der zukunft weil man sagt okay alles klar wir mussten doch nochmal eine änderung vornehmen dass man eben beim einsammeln dieser dann auch sieht ok das ist noch das alte protokoll das ist das neue protokoll damit man weiß wie man das lesen kann.
Und außerdem senden sie jetzt noch mit mit welcher sendeleistung.
Das telefon vermutlich dieses paket ausgesendet hat mit welcher sünde stärke man es empfängt das weiß man ja selber beim empfang.
Wir hatten das glaube ich angenommen dass das standard ist ne.
Genau wir hatten das eigentlich angenommen dass hier so machen also hätte ich jetzt ja.
Genau das war dann sozusagen mir auch nicht klar dass das eben standardmäßig so wahrscheinlich nicht drin ist jetzt ist es explizit mit,
dabei und außerdem haben sie noch mal so zwei felder auch nochmal hinzugefügt die frei sind also da gibt es sozusagen noch zwei,
unbelebt sind die jetzt aber da sind in dieser in diesem diesem dateninnhalte man pilot nennt weil man weiß ja nicht was vielleicht noch in zukunft noch erforderlich ist und
das wäre dann eben möglich ohne dass man das,
in seiner größe nochmal groß ändern müsste diese sendeleistung wird dann eben mit so minus hundertsiebenundzwanzig,
plus hundertsiebenundzwanzig dcm kodiert das ist ja so ein in der technischen diskussion dieses protokoll eine sache die,
sehr stark debattiert wird also viele techniker haben sich zu wort gemeldet und haben halt.
Angezweifelt dass man mit diesem bluetooth das was hier überhaupt gemacht werden soll überhaupt durchführbar ist und ich würde sagen das ist zu diesem zeitpunkt auch unbewiesenen also,
werden wir sehen ja kann sein dass wir am ende feststellen dass das alles nichts genützt hat und man sich vielleicht mal in zukunft bei den netzwerkprotokoll darüber mal gedanken machen muss
wie man für solche fälle vorsorge treffen kann aber wir müssen ja mit dem arbeiten was wir jetzt haben und das ist dann
das maximum was man eben jetzt tun kann man sagt einfach ich habe so laut gesendet und du hast so laut empfangen und dann versucht ihr mannheim draus zu machen
muss man sehen was dabei rauskommt es gab dann noch eine änderung.
In der kryptographie die ist vielleicht nicht ganz so wichtig ich muss auch zugeben dass mich ich ärgere mich fast dass ich das nicht gleich
am anfang mit angesprochen habe weil mir kam es immer schon so ein bisschen überflüssig vor es gab da so in eine kaskade dass man irgendwie sagt jedes telefon was anfängt mit dem tracking erzeugt sich so ein masterkey und daraus werden dann
immer täglich diese anderen daily erzeugt man hat jetzt diesen mastercard einfach komplett
fallen gelassen weil er eigentlich überhaupt nicht erforderlich ist wichtig ist nur dass die einzelnen tage unterschiedliche kryptografisch,
basieren haben damit man diese tage einzeln melden kann aber die tage an sich nicht zusammenhängen,
das ist auch nach wie vor so dann sind die dinge ein bisschen umbenannt worden man spricht also jetzt von so einem temporary exposé aus dem dann eben all diese ganzen dies die letztlich wirklich versendet werden.
Abgeleitet werden und diese metadaten ist uns ganz interessant sind wir jetzt nicht genau erklären aber im prinzip ist es so die sind.
Wenn man sie empfängt erstmal gar nicht lesbar sondern,
die sind indirekt nochmal mit den ganzen anderen schlüsseln so verknüpft.
Dass man nur wenn man eben von dem netzwerk so einen.
Von einem infizierten bekommen nur dann kann man diese metadaten auch lesen das heißt die taugen nicht zum drecken taugen nicht zum erkennen weil es könnte ja sein okay hier die sendeleistung
so wie sich das verhält das ist so typisch iphone man hätte quasi aus diesem daten herauslesen können so okay.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein iphone und.
Na ja.
Dass man das eben erst im allerletzten schritt machen kann aber einfach nur so einsammeln bringt alles nichts.
Nur ums nochmal jetzt.
Zu klären weil das hatte ich nämlich glaube ich bei der als du mir das erklärt hattest falsch verstanden oder.
Ja ich hatte nämlich irgendwie mitgenommen in meinem gedächtnis des sagen wenn du irgendwas hochlädst dass du das.
Dass du das hochlädst was du empfangen hast tatsächlich aber so wie ich als ich dann nachgelesen habe ist es so dass du ja.
Sagen hochlädst was du ausgesendet hast an kies.
Richtig das ist das das ist das prinzip des dezentralen modells du empfängst und alles was du empfängst bleibt auf dem telefon.
Genau das ist das ist nämlich genau der der der punkt das ist genau das das das was du empfängst halt und das dementsprechend,
natürlich auch weil das das nie das telefon verlässt das telefon aber auch eigentlich,
sagen nur ja die feststellung treffen kann ob da jetzt ein gefährlicher kontakt war oder nicht.
Genau das ist das prinzip und das ist halt genau bei dem zentralen modell,
andersrum gewesen in dem moment wo ich mich als infiziert melde gebe ich nicht die raus die ich gesendet habe sondern ich gebe die all dies raus die ich empfangen habe
das ist der entscheidende unterschied hier bei dem modell was er jetzt das modell ist ist es so ich.
Höhere höhere höhere höhere schreibe auf und so weiter und diese ganzen all dies werden erstmal nur gespeichert.
Und ich merke mir dann nur welche ich in diesen tagen gesendet habe und den moment wo ich infiziert bin gebe ich der welt bekannt okay ich bin jetzt hier der infizierte
das hier sind diese vierzehn täglichen kies die ich verwendet habe aus denen
über den tag verlauf diese ganzen unterschiedlichen generiert worden das heißt es geht wirklich nur diese vierzehn kies raus und.
Für andere sind es auch vierzehn einzelne tage man weiß in dem moment eigentlich noch nicht mal mehr dass die vierzehn alle zu einem telefon gehören.
So jetzt werden wir also sehen dass auf basis dieses protokoll zumindest in deutschland in der schweiz österreich.
Estland das sind so die länder die bisher gesagt haben okay da ziehen wir jetzt mit.
Bleibt jetzt noch abzuwarten wie sich frankreich verhält bleibt auch abzuwarten,
wie sich das auf eu-ebene entwickelt da sieht's aber schon so aus also die eu gremien parlament haben sich auch relativ klar hinter einem dezentralen ansatz,
versammelt und einfach die tatsache dass eigentlich das andere modell nicht wirklich effizient durchführbar ist.
Mir dass wir hier mittelfristig das zu so einem goldstandard machen werden vielleicht wird es ein paar länder geben die sich bis zum schluss dagegen wehren
gerade so aus als ob die da ihre überwachung noch nicht aufgegeben haben mein gefühl sagt mir dieses dezentrale modell wird sich durchsetzen und dann werden wir vielleicht auch langfristig so ein internationales roaming von diesem ganzen notifications sehen.
Bleibt natürlich jetzt die frage.
Wo kriegen wir denn jetzt diese anderen informationen die uns das zentrale modell gegeben hätte und ich wurde auch wenig.
Kritisiert ich hätte das ja nicht ausreichend gewürdigt aber der punkt ist.
Das ist halt was anderes und jetzt muss man eben sehen okay wie könnte in so einem modell auch noch eine information generiert werden.
Damit man eben vielleicht bessere parameter hat und eine bessere voraussagen der entwicklung von allem hat weil was jetzt erstmal wegfällt ist ja folgendes nochmal der fall.
Jemand ist.
Getestet infiziert hat die app verwendet vierzehn tage lang damit durch die gegend gerannt und viele andere telefone gesehen.
In diesem im rahmen dieses prozesses mit hallo ich gebe jetzt bekannt das sind die vierzehn die ich in den letzten vierzehn tagen verwendet habe oder diese vierzehn schlüssel aus denen sich diese ableiten kann,
regnet diese daten dieser datensatz jetzt auf alle anderen telefon in nieder.
Die schauen sich das an gucken sich das dann da rein gehen ihre liste durch und sagen so ja nee habe ich nie gesehen kein problem oder eben.
Echt an dem tag habe ich gesehen und.
Da habe ich auch irgendwie länger daneben gestanden dieses protokoll das ist jetzt auch nochmal spezifiziert löst die zeit so in so fünf minuten chance aus man muss halt mindestens fünf minuten lang in der nähe sein bis man.
Von einem kontakt spricht,
und sie haben übrigens auch noch die api geändert das habe ich gar nicht gesagt sie haben auch noch diese geändert dass man eben auch parameter mit reingeben kann man kann sagen okay,
die und die signal stärken,
die ignoriere ich oder so und so fein aufgelöst möchte ich das haben also sie haben schon etwas geboten wo man eben mehr interpretationsspielraum auch von der,
mit in diese prüfung mit reinbringen kann die prüfung wird immer noch von dem telefon selber gemacht und man kann halt auch sagen welche zeiten man sozusagen mindestens haben will ob man die eher länger oder eher
kürzer halten will kriegt aber dann das ganze nur in so einer zehn minuten auflösung genannt.
Also so richtig auf die sekunde genau wird es eh nicht innerhalb so zehn minuten chance kriegt man das so jetzt,
haben die telefone die im kontakt hatten mit dieser infizierten person haben diese information jetzt bekommen und können den user sagen okay,
exporter notification ich sag dir mal bescheid weil du warst hier expost meiner meinung nach meine daten sagen du warst da ausreichend in der nähe du hast eine zeit verbracht ihr habt da zusammen im park gesessen was weiß ich mit den gehabt was auch immer.
Und jetzt die.
Dann kommt halt diese app hoch und sagt hier ich muss dir mal was sagen wird dir vielleicht nicht gefallen damit weiß es der user.
Und das kann jetzt der anlass sein kann sein dass das telefon hochkommt und sagt hier r code damit kannst du zu testing abteilung gehen und kannst dich sofort testen lassen aber was man ja.
Eben auch ursprünglich haben wollte in diesem zentralen ansatz war dass man eben diese information mit wie vielen leuten war denn diese person in kontakt die hätte man auch ganz gerne.
Die hätten in dem zentralen modell auch die information bekommen wer das war also photonik aber immerhin na also man kann die unterscheiden jetzt sind aber diese informationen erstmal nur auf den telefon.
Und es gibt da diese behörden die sagen so wir hätten diese daten so gerne wir lieben eure privatsphäre und datenschutz und wir haben das jetzt auch alles verstanden und kein problem aber gibt's nicht doch noch irgendwie einen weg wie wir diese informationen
bekommen können.
Und ist natürlich die frage wie verhält sich jetzt diese app letztlich ist es ja immer noch die nationale corona tracing app die.
Das telefon anweist hier kies überprüf mal und dann kriegt ihr die nachricht so okay ja kontakt hat stattgefunden und sie soll es natürlich den user sagen aber natürlich könnt ihr diese app ist genauso auch irgendjemand anders sagen automatisch.
Ja nicht dass diese person infiziert ist sondern nur dass sie in kontakt war an der stelle ist es natürlich wichtig hier.
App muss open source sein muss überprüft werden dass dass das nicht einfach raus rauscht weil dann ist der ganze privat vorteil natürlich gleich wieder weg an der stelle.
Vertrauen ist gut kontrolle ist besser das auf jeden fall nochmal ein wichtiger punkt aber sagen wir mal die app ist ordentlich programmiert dahingehend dass es nicht gleich pads sondern dass sie den user entscheiden lässt und jetzt ist die frage wie könnte man auf den user
zugehen man könnte ja sagen hör mal.
Du bist jetzt hier exponiert ich habe zwar keine ahnung ob du dir jetzt ein virus eingefangen hast aber allein diese information dass du mit einem infizierten am nachgewiesenermaßen infizierten zusammen gewesen bist.
Könnte uns helfen weil wir das in unserem modelle einbauen können das ist ja sozusagen das was die sich erhoffen.
Und jetzt wird sicherlich überlegt werden das weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau dass es nur meine annahme dass man dann eben hochkommt und sagt so ja hier ey total besorgnis,
teil uns das doch mal mit so ähnlich wie das diese daten spende behauptet hat.
Ja kannst du uns schon sagen deine deine deine anonymität ist gewahrt
wir wollen einfach nur diese information haben wir wollen einfach nur dieses der da der da gerade irgendwie sich gemeldet hat war mit dir in kontakt diese information hätten wir einfach ganz gerne.
Hallo,
tja und jetzt die frage will man sowas also es ist das dann akzeptabel geht dann das geschrei wieder los wahrscheinlich geht das geschrei los.
Ist das eine information.
Die die gesellschaft so ein anrecht hätte oder kann man nachvollziehen dass wir diese information gerne haben wollen wenn denn die modellieren der meinung sind das würde ihnen weiterhelfen ja vielleicht.
Könnte sein meiner meinung nach könnte es so laufen in dem moment wo du dich testen lässt.
In dem moment wo du dein abstrich abgibst ja bekommst du im prinzip schon so eine tan.
Das ist quasi dein deine tür dich als infiziert zu melden mit der app.
Die funktioniert aber noch nicht ja die ist sozusagen noch gar nicht da dann kommt das ergebnis zurück.
Du bekommst mitgeteilt übrigens hier dran jetzt kannst du mal bei deiner app die taste drücken so dann drückst du da.
Die tasse ich melde mich jetzt als infiziert kannst du es aber nur wirklich los schicken wenn du eben diese tat hast sonst gibt's diese funktion einfach gar nicht.
Dann werden deine daten übermittelt aber diese tan führt auch nicht zur veröffentlichung davon,
das kommt sozusagen erstmal nur im system an und erst wenn auf der anderen seite auch noch bestätigt wird.
Diese tan hier die wir uns notiert haben bei abgabe dieses tests die ist jetzt auch positiv dann geht das ganze durch.
Das ist der eine teil wo,
rausgegeben wird an der stelle braucht man auch keine weitere datenspeicher weil die hat man im prinzip in dem moment ja erhalten und man weiß von diesem fall ja sowieso schon so und da gehen dann auch
die manuellen dressings los was man aber haben will ist diese auswertung der anderen telefonen die dann eine stunde später feststellen es gab diese exposé.
Und da könnte man natürlich jetzt anfangen zu betteln und dann wird es geschrei halt irgendwie groß ein anderer ansatz wäre.
Dass man diese informationen einfach über so ein differenzial privacy feature einsammelt.
Differential privacy ist ja noch ein relativ modernes konzept das gibt es erst glaube ich seit.
Fünf sechs jahren oder so ist das mal als paper rausgekommen und wurde dann aber auch relativ schnell umgesetzt apple hat das glaube ich.
Als erstes mit umgesetzt also zumindest latsch aber auch bei microsoft auch bei google kommt das alles zum
einsatz und man sieht es zum beispiel sehr schön bei diesem
mobility trends die sie jetzt veröffentlicht haben sie haben ja aus ihren ganzen kartenmaterial dem was die telefone ja selber wissen wie sehr sich die user bewegen also all diese ganzen informationen die
karl auf dem telefon anfallen die,
telefonaten schon selber eine ganz gute vorstellung davon was man macht wie sehr man sich bewegt womit man sich bewegt fährt mein auto geht man zu fuß etcetera schrittezähler all diese ganzen geschichten die da mit reinkommen aber natürlich sind das
hoch private informationen auf der anderen seite sind das natürlich auch extrem nützliche informationen wenn man die hätte,
nur eben dann wieder privatsphäre dasselbe problem wie jetzt eben auch bei den gesundheitsdaten.
Und den weg den man da geht ist man sammelt diese informationen schon ein die telefone senden diese information tatsächlich,
aber sie verwenden eben dieses prinzip der differential privacy und das bedeutet dass man zwar schon daten schickt,
aber eben nur mit einer bestimmten wahrscheinlichkeit die richtigen sprich,
es wird so eine art rauschen in diese daten mit reingebracht wird so ein,
ein definierter fehler erzeugt und man je nach algorithmus und wie man das einstellt kann man diesen fehler größer oder oder oder kleiner machen aber das resultat davon ist dass obwohl zwar daten berichtet werden.
Man erstens nicht weiß,
von wem weil die an sich erstmal anonym sind und man kann sie aber auch nicht wirklich auf so ein telefon zurückführen weil klar gibt's ein telefon das hat eine interesse und und und und liefert jetzt daten an aber man weiß nicht ob die daten stimmen,
man weiß nur dass die daten über alle telefone verteilt in der summe wenn man das rauschen wieder rausrechnet.
Stimmen und mit so einem ähnlichen ansatz könnte man vielleicht.
Hier auch arbeiten also ich will eigentlich jetzt auch gar keinen konkreten vorschlag machen oder behaupten ich wäre jetzt hier der informatik professor der das alles durchgerechnet ich sage nur das sind die debatten die uns jetzt
bevorstehen wir werden halt diskutieren müssen inwiefern diese apps freiwilligkeit einklagen oder inwiefern man,
eine automatisierung vielleicht auch macht und die privatsphäre quasi systemisch sichert,
damit eben aber auch wieder ein vorsprung bekommen kann weil man eben mit dem infizierten auch sofort die informationen bekommt okay dieser infizierte ist jetzt aufgenommen worden,
der hat so und so viele leute gesehen ja und vielleicht.
Anderen begleitet informationen aber bleiben wir einfach mal nur bei der zahl wenn ich die information bekomme hat niemanden gesehen ist auch eine information.
Innerhalb eines bestimmten
bericht zeitraums etcetera aber man sieht halt so ah okay der war mit sehr vielen leuten unterwegs sind einfach informationen die man an der stelle vielleicht gewinnen könnt also es ist schwierig
diese freischaltung richtig zu bekommen und es ist schwierig auch diesen rest hinzubekommen um mich wundert es jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt immer weniger umso mehr ich darüber nachdenke dass sie jetzt ausgerechnet sap damit beauftragt haben.
Hier aktiv zu werden nicht weil ich der meinung bin dass sap ein großartiges.
Komme und sap oder.
Telekom und sap ja genau und zwar ist es ganz interessant weil die beiden
unternehmen sind nämlich schon involviert in diesen ganzen korona datenkrake das ist jetzt nicht so dass
jetzt aus mittagsschlaf gerufen wurden sondern
die sind schon beteiligt und zwar weiß nicht ob das jetzt die einzige aktivität ist aber das ist so das was ich hier im web gefunden habe ist nämlich gerade dabei gerade dieses problem
der des manuellen contact tracing bei den gesundheitsämtern.
Zu unterstützen also den gesundheitsämtern überhaupt erstmal software zu geben mit denen sie das manuelle dressing besser organisieren können sprich die sind,
mindestens mit diesem projekt,
schon genau an dieser schnittstelle um die es jetzt gerade geht von daher nicht so überraschend für mich jetzt das.
Das die jetzt hier gerufen wurden ob die das verkacken keine ahnung ja was sie drauf haben ich weiß es nicht kann immer was schief gehen aber das,
scheint nicht so ganz falsch zu sein und die telekom.
Die telekom ist auch beteiligt und zwar haben die mit ihrer healthcare sektion eine app entwickelt die diese rückmeldung der tests.
Macht also sind beide unternehmen sind offensichtlich hier schon.
An projekten dran die genau mit diesem prozess was zu tun haben nämlich dieses wie organisierte
gesundheitsamt ihr manuelles tracing auf der einen seite und falle der telekom wie erreichen die testergebnisse den user.
Und das macht das macht schon sinn.
An der stelle das zusammenzurücken oder es macht den eindruck dass es sinnvoll sein könnte die zusammenzubringen und zu sagen okay kümmert euch jetzt mal um die app
diese information dieser exporter notification vom telefon in in verbindung bringt mit.
Den gesundheitsämtern mit dem tracing etcetera das alles zusammenzubringen und ich glaube da stehen uns noch einige datenschutz diskussionen bevor in der konkreten ausprägung wie das laufen wird,
aber ich habe zumindest nicht den eindruck dass sie jetzt komplett,
irgendwelche leute geholt haben die gerade mal einen großen namen hatten.
Ja also bin beneiden tue ich hier auch nicht um die aufgabe muss ich ehrlich gesagt,
sagen es ist es kann eigentlich nur schiefgehen so es ist auch.
Ganz unschöne.
Gemengelage und zeitdruck und große politische aufmerksamkeit und eigentlich auch.
Ja wir sind jetzt beide nicht
unbedingt dafür bekannt jetzt superschnell dinge zu machen sondern ich meine die müssen die dinge halt eher sorgfältig machen so hier ist halt sagen beides gefragt
und eigentlich ja hatten wir uns ja glaube ich auch in der letzten sendung schon mal kurz diese die chinesische methode angesprochen wenn man irgendwas
schnell und mit einer hohen wahrscheinlichkeit haben möchte dass man dann,
parallel einfach mehrere firmen und teams darauf ansetzt die genau dasselbe machen.
Da gleich mal gleich einzuhaken da bin ich auch voll dabei.
Wenn es sich um etwas handelt was sozusagen prototypen phase ist also diese ganze phase als alle noch überlegt haben wie macht man in dieses dressing an sich überhaupt technisch und so weiter das genau der richtige bereich dafür hier glaube ich sind wir aber an einem anderen punkt angekommen wo es nämlich jetzt wirklich wichtig ist
leute zu finden die auch diesen schwierigen teil mit der verknüpfung mit der real welt
hinbekommen weil das ist sozusagen das aber letzte was ich dazu sage da dadurch dass man das dezentrale modell von apple und google jetzt nimmt.
Trennt man nämlich tatsächlich wie das jetzt sicher auch im protokoll nahm wiederfindet diese eigentliche benachrichtigung.
Von diesem ganzen anderen prozess mit wie können wir da noch mehr daten gewinnen ohne datenschutz und privatsphäre unnötig zu strapazieren man kann diesen ersten teil der app.
Müsste man eigentlich schnell hinbekommen ich meine die schweizer wollen jetzt im mai starten.
Weil letzten endes muss das ding nur in anführungsstrichen dieses problem der meldung lösen und danach wird es halt komplexer.
Wo wo stehen wir denn jetzt im moment zeit planmäßig weil du sagtest gut prototypen.
Ich habe auch.
Also eigentlich das was ich bisher gesehen habe hat den namen prototyp eigentlich kaum verdient gehabt aber es gibt,
bestimmt viele gruppen die irgendwie schon weiter sind nur das problem ist ja so apple.
Hat ja noch nicht noch noch kein oder so rausgegeben das heißt man kann im moment noch gar keine prototypen betreiben oder sehe ich das falsch.
Also tatsächlich war das release und ich schaue gerade mal ob's stattgefunden hat für heute angekündigt.
Apple hat gesagt dass sie am achtundzwanzigsten april also heute das das erste fremdwort releasen wollen.
Ich weiß nicht ob sich das gehalten hat jetzt lese ich gerade was von ersten mai das kann also sein dass das nochmal um drei tage nach hinten geschoben ist.
Also ich hatte auch irgendwie anfangen mai war meine meine kenntnis dass sie halt ja damit rauskommen wollen.
Die app die ist ja nicht besonders schwierig oder anspruchsvoll oder groß ist kann man wahrscheinlich prototypen in einem tag oder zweien sogar runter hacken und gut aber das ist dann,
halt nur einen prototyp die server seite ja.
Die ist auch nicht super komplex aber hat natürlich eigene herausforderungen so bei skalierbarkeit und natürlich ja also jede menge anforderungen und eigentlich.
Also ich kenne so wenn man irgendwie ein system.
Am start bringen will indem man das viele mobiltelefone verwickelt sind dann.
Ist das nicht so einfach straight vorwort sondern diese telefone und diese netze machen halt komische dinge,
so da gehen halt pakete verloren aber auf ganz komische art und weise teilweise und
also es ist nicht sondern sondern internet mit ganz vielen mobiltelefon ist halt kein besonders freundliche umgebung in der praxis so das heißt.
Da brauchst du auch immer eine gewisse zeit bis bis es irgendwie,
halbwegs stabil und richtig läuft und
am anfang musste simulatoren an den start bringen allein aber nur hunderttausende oder millionen von telefon zu simulieren ist ein problem.
Ja also an an ganz ganz ganz vielen stellen einfach du
du musst das ganze in instrumentieren du hast auch das gegenteil von einem mann gut du hast zwar auch einen content
delivery service aber du hast halt letztlich auch einen musste jetzt jetzt den content auch einsammeln auch wenn das wahrscheinlich pro tag,
nicht allzu viel sein wird sondern dass das problem ist tatsächlich schon das durch zu verteilen aber ja also.
Man technik ist ist weit und was man so in einer cloud alles machen kann so ist auch ganz nett
meine erfahrung ist dass sind immer das braucht wochen und monate manchmal um sich einzuruckeln selbst wenn der code funktional eigentlich schon.
Da komplett und vollständig ist wovon ja auch noch keine rede sein kann und sagt bundesregierung sagt also auf jeden fall nicht im mai.
Ich sehe ich jetzt auch noch nicht dass das im mai wirklich fertig ist
aber mal schauen das ist meine das ganze wird eine gewisse dynamik bekommen in dem moment wo erstmal die framework und letzten endes auch die betriebssystem integration
da ist dann werden wir nämlich sehen dass es mindestens ein land gibt wo es sehr schnell geht.
Vorne.
So das war auch meine vermutung dass ungefähr wahrscheinlich zwölf stunden nach dem apple den kam raushaut oder das bestimmt schon wer weiß
irgendwelche leute die eng an apple dran sitzen schon vielleicht ein bisschen ein informationsvorsprung haben und eigentlich schon schon was.
Apple wird natürlich dazu zur kalifornischen zum zum gouverneur die als die haben da eine taskforce die da gibt's irgendwo so eine etage.
Und da sitzen die alle.
Und das das wird nicht lange dauern also apple wird nicht in kalifornien was veröffentlichen und dann dauert's nummer drei wochen bis da irgendwie eine app kommt sondern,
das läuft schon ja das das das das das wird einfach stattfinden das heißt wir werden dort sehen wie gut es funktionieren kann wir werden eine app sehen.
Wie die benutzt wird es werden informationen darüber rauskommen wie deren modell ist welche entscheidungen die gefällt haben wo gegen die sich entschieden haben etcetera das wird relativ schnell klar werden und dann wird man sogar vielleicht
vielleicht auch schon erste erfolge erzielen können denkbar.
Vielleicht erstmal im kleinen aber wir wissen dass es alles die smartphone dichte in kalifornien kann ich nicht beziffern aber dieses hoch ja.
Technik gläubigkeit der amerikaner ist unerreicht ja also es ist einfach wenn einer daran glaubt dass man mit zukunft immer alles lösen kann dann
amerika und dann auf jeden fall vor allem erstmal kalifornien das heißt das ist so das hot bett da werden sich diese entwicklung machen während sich die
ja jetzt wahrscheinlich nochmal drei wochen lang gegen die schienbeine stoße bis ihr dann irgendwann dadrauf kommt dass es dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher ist an einem strang zu ziehen.
Und dann werden wir das hier auch sehen und dann wird man schauen ob es irgendwas gebracht hat oder nicht.
Ja ich denke das ist so alles was man jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt auch dazu erstmal sagen kann also in der zusammenfassung es ist zeit gewonnen worden dadurch dass man nicht,
indem man beschlossen hat nicht weitere zeit zu verlieren ja indem man sich hier in weitere fights begibt das ist schon mal gut.
Technisch geht es voran es sind eine menge fragen noch zu klären.
Aber die kann man auch klären und es sind vor allem erstmal keine battles die so an,
an den kern gehen sondern da kann sich können sich jetzt erstmal kritische komponenten schnell ausrollen
und das werden wir sicherlich auch sehen mitte mai nehme ich mal an wird es eine große zahl an system geben auf den die weißes und dann werden wir sehen.
Wie sieht das alles dann darstellt.
Also also ich rechne ja mit einer mittelgroßen katastrophe.
Nicht nicht weil ich irgendwie das ganze schlecht reden will sondern eigentlich immer wenn man bei.
It-projekte irgendwie zumindest ja probleme vorhersage so da braucht man.
Wie der experte noch irgendwie der große guru zu sein sondern es ist eigentlich die norm.
Es wäre doch sehr beeindruckend wenn unter dem zeitdruck unter der öffentlichen aufmerksamkeit und unter dieser ganzen gemengelage.
Am ende sitzen da müssen sitzender entwickler die müssen coach schreiben und die müssen die pläne dokumentieren müssen halt dinge tun so und zwar schnell.
Ja aber oft leiden doch auch diese projekte darunter dass sie eben nicht in der öffentlichkeit sind.
Da wird dann einfach jahrelang rum geschoben und die deadlines wuschen vorbei und es gibt
zu keine keine keine persönliche motivation hier schneller zu machen aber hier sind halt alle betroffen das ist nicht so das projekt was du mal so eben verkacken kannst das steht schon im fokus und an der stelle kann es auch ein vorteil sein weil du christi
die mittel du kriegst die aufmerksamkeit,
die sinne sind geschärft und man weiß auch man muss hier mal vorankommen dass das ist jetzt sozusagen etwas wo man nicht scheitern will,
vorstellen dass er sowohl bei sap als auch bei der telekom das ding ist einfach mal ganz oben aufgehangen das ist jetzt nicht irgend so ein auftrag den sie entgegengenommen haben und der für irgendeinen kunden dann irgendwann mal umgesetzt wird.
Was denkst du wann kriegen wir das von telekom und sap das erste gitarre positiv mit code zu sehen.
Naja also die open source debatte wird da sicherlich auch nochmal geführt werden müssen denke ich mal das ist so das.
Unabhängig von open source unabhängig von open source es geht mir nur um sozusagen einblicke also um transparenz erstmal also es kann ja,
nach wie vor ihrer code sein aber da wäre da ja eher alle reingucken können so erwarte ich eigentlich wie das in vielen industriebereich mittlerweile ja in vielen bereichen wo es
um was geht ist also was weiß ich in der smart contract kryptos zähne oder so da packst du natürlich dein coach
vorher einfach auch in den gitarre gehört das zum standard dazu ja das ist da ist das nichts besonderes sondern das ist sozusagen das mindeste was du machen musst um irgendwie,
vertrauen zu erwecken und deswegen ja also ganz ganz praktisch jetzt ich meine.
Wann erwartest du das erste also den ersten einblick in den quelle code von klein und zaubern.
Also ich habe schwierigkeiten mich da jetzt auf irgendeine zeit festzulegen weil ich glaube.
Ich kann gerade jetzt noch niemand diese nachricht mit telekom sap brandneu irgendwie die habe ich jetzt irgendwie zwei stunden vor diesem podcast zur kenntnis genommen und.
Meine mutmaßung inwieweit die jetzt da in irgendwas involviert sind.
Ist auch erstmal nur so ein so ein zwischenstand warum ich das sage ist ich weiß ja gar nicht.
Was die teams da für tools haben was sie überhaupt einsetzen also wenn die jetzt auf irgendwelchen party fremdwort aufbauen die sie nicht so ohne weiteres veröffentlichen können dann wird es da wahrscheinlich nochmal eine debatte geben.
Ich weiß es nicht ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man hier in zwei drei wochen schon mal einen schritt weiter ist.
Na ja wie gesagt war jetzt nur so ein also das mit dem positiv war jetzt nur so ein beispiel wie auch mein nicht dass ich denen das nicht zutrauen würde,
so dass das auch zu machen aber da werden.
Glaube ich dort auch verschiedene kulturen einfach erstmal noch aufeinander stoßen und sap und telekom haben sicherlich auch super leute.
Aber die sind natürlich weiß nicht.
Ja teilweise schon teilweise noch andere art zu arbeiten gewohnt wobei man die nicht unterschätzen.
Sollte auch vielleicht kriegen sie's ja auf moderne art und weise hin aber es.
Ich meine das system wird auch nicht einfach zu testen sein erstmal in diesem system wird erstmal nicht so richtig viel passieren auch das ist wahrscheinlich auch das das das problem so und ja
und.
Also ich ich war gut schlecht ist das auch nur der traum ne dass man das irgendwie geben mehr gamification muss noch weil ja,
konkret die app wird für enttäuschung sagen auch bei ganz vielen
leuten wurde so viel dann drüber geredet und die macht aber eigentlich erstmal nicht viel was du siehst du macht eigentlich gar nichts also bei meisten leuten wird sie auch nie irgendetwas tun also was die merken
dass sie merken dass ihre app irgendwas tut.
Und ja ich war keine ahnung vielleicht ist das auch okay so vielleicht ist es auch gut so aber ich denke die leute werden enttäuscht sein.
So wenn sie kommt sie nichts macht so richtig.
Sie soll ja auch nicht viel machen soll einfach nur da sein und so weiter man in österreich wird tatsächlich auch so features diskutiert dass man halt warnung auch zurücknehmen kann oder dass man auch was ein bisschen schwierig ist
dass man auch symptome symptom basiert so eine meldung machen kann das ding ist.
Man kann sich jetzt viel einfallen lassen was man da alles noch reinpacken kann.
Aber wenn man sich wenn man die größe hätte sich zu beschränken und zu sagen lass uns erstmal den kern.
Ausrollen das ist erstmal die minimalfunktionen die muss laufen und wenn das läuft und wenn das,
tanz findet in einem zweiten schritt dann kann man noch mehr machen und dann kann man noch mehr machen und dann werden wir sehen ob es funktioniert und ob es hilft so das ist auf jeden fall meiner meinung nach der weg den man gehen sollte.
Gut pavel ich glaube dann haben wir jetzt erstmal soweit alles zusammengefegt was ich diese woche so zusammenfegen lässt.
Mal schauen was sich bei der abtut sonst können wir das thema vielleicht auch erstmal wieder so ein bisschen abkühlen lassen ich glaube da ist ziemlich viel gesagt aber vielleicht holt uns die nachrichtenlage nächste woche schon wieder an ansonsten gucken wir mal,
wie unsere grafiken sich so entwickeln und vielleicht sind wir dann schon wieder schlauer.
Ja hoffen wir das beste.
Alles klar ja.
Vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei u k w wir machen hier nächste woche weiter gibt vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen andere einblicke hier auf diesem kanal an dieser stelle auch nochmal vielen dank für.
Eure unterstützung dieses formats und alle anderen formate der metaebene das hilft auf jeden fall sehr ich sage.